1245, Ich werde meine Ersatzungen bestätigen. Mathematik ist die Sprache der Natur. Alles, was uns herum steht, kann durch Nummern verstanden werden. Deswegen gibt es Schrauben, überall in der. Natur. So was ist mit dem Markt? Das Universum von Nummern, das die globale Wirtschaft betrifft, Millionen von Menschen, Billionen von Minen, eine große Netzwerkte, mit Leben schreien. Ein Organismus, ein natürliches Organismus. Meine Hypothese, in dem Markt gibt es auch einen Pattern.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 202. Ausgabe von CRE. Und heute geht es um kulturelles. Der Versuch, mal ein wenig zurück zu blättern im Filmarchiv der Geschichte und auf die Suche zu gehen nach Spuren der Hackerkultur. Wie die sich dort widerspiegelt und entwickelt hat und was uns das vielleicht über dieselbe wiederum sagt. Ja, und da ich da selber eigentlich gar nicht so viel Überblick habe, dachte ich mir, lade ich mal Caspar ein. Caspar Clemens Mierau, hallo. Caspar, auch bekannt als das Leitmedium, einer, der das Twitter-Accounten hat, worauf man nördisch sein kann und sich immer denkt, warum bin ich da nicht drauf gekommen?
Ich habe auch Leitmedium mit D, für alle Fälle.
Nicht schlecht. Du bist sozusagen für alle Fälle gerüstet. Genau, aber du bist ja auch ein wacher Begleiter der Digitalkultur im Allgemeinen, würde ich sagen. Hast du ein bisschen deine Finger ausgestreckt, das eine oder andere zu, ja, auch mal mit einem etwas anderen Blick zu versehen, als das normalerweise der Fall ist. Was, ja, wo kommst du eigentlich her? Ja, also ich meine, was hast du denn so für ein, was hat dich denn an das Digitale so herangeführt? Bist du auch früh in irgendeinen Zaubertopf gefallen oder?
Gar nicht.
Was hast du gemacht?
Ich komme aus Berlin, also aus Ostberlin komme ich. Hab ja noch elf Jahre vor der Wende miterlebt, da war es nicht ganz so einfach in den Zaubertopf zu fallen.
Ja, möglich, aber schwierig.
Genau, ein bisschen möglich war es. Es gab an der Rosenthaler Straße das Jungpionierzentrum, das jetzt glaube ich eine Waldorfschule ist. Rosenthaler Straße, Ecke, Ah, da in der Mitte. Genau, Ecke, Gipsstraße, da, genau. Berlin Mitte. Genau, Berlin Mitte, Berlin Mitte Ost. Rote Backsteinbau, da gab es ein Jungpionierzentrum und da gab es Computerkurse auf den Robotronencomputern.
KC 85.
Genau, auf denen habe ich Basic programmiert. Ich habe sogar irgendwann noch mal so eine Art Tagebuch gefunden aus der dritten Klasse, da werde ich also acht, neun Jahre alt gewesen sein, wo so handschriftliche Basic-Programme drin waren, die ich da geschrieben habe. Das war so der erste Zaubertopf und ich hatte einen Onkel, der an der Humboldt-Universität im Bereich Psychologie die Technik betreut hat und die haben natürlich schon früh Statistik gemacht und der hat dann Sinclair zu Hause, den bin ich immer am Wochenende, wenn ich durfte, besuchen gegangen und durfte bei dem von der Datasette Spiele spielen. Das waren so die zwei Beratungspunkte. Ansonsten komme ich eigentlich aus so einem kulturellen Haushalt, eher so Theaterhaushalt. Deswegen war das immer so ein, es gab so dieses Bedürfnis nach Technik, das habe ich mir sozusagen draußen geholt. Zu Hause eher das die Gespräche über schön geistige Themen, was aber dann natürlich so ein bisschen so ein Spannungsbogen irgendwie aufmacht und das hat sich dann so ein bisschen fortgepflanzt, weil ich nicht Informatik studiert habe, das habe ich überlegt, ob ich es tue, sondern Kulturwissenschaft, besser gesagt Medienkulturwissenschaft in Weimar, wo man sich halt mit Medien im weitesten Sinne auseinandersetzt oder überhaupt der Frage, was Medien sind und dadurch natürlich eine bestimmte Herangehensweise an Dinge bekommt. Das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum man und meiner Meinung nach oft in der Universität geht, dass man so eine Herangehensweise lernt. Und diese Medienkulturwissenschaftliche Herangehensweise ist halt eine Herangehensweise, die ich jetzt auf viele Dinge, würde ich sagen, übertrage.
Technik plus Kultur gleich Technik. Kultur kann man sozusagen zusammenfassen. So, dann kam die Wende und alles brach über dich hinein.
Genau, dann kam die große Frage, was ich für einen Computer geschenkt haben will. Heute im Nachhinein weiß ich erst, was das ja für eine große Entscheidung war. Amiga oder C64. Ich habe mich über den C64 entschieden. Ich bereue es glaube ich ein bisschen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. So im Nachhinein. Ich hatte damals aber immer das Problem, dass ich keine richtigen Nerd-Freunde hatte. Es gab einfach keine in meinem Umfeld. Jedenfalls der C64 brach über mich herein, dann irgendwann so in der Mitte der 90er-Mailbox-Szene so ein bisschen mitgemacht als Nutzer irgendwie, aber schon noch mit einem 2-4er-Modem irgendwo eingewählt. Also das habe ich noch miterlebt.
Das prägt ja auch sehr.
Ja, also das Spannende daran ist, dass man halt so diese Technikevolution miterlebt hat. Vom 2-4er zum 9-6er-Modem, 14-4er und so. Diese Geräusche kann man ja auch heute noch so halbwegs auseinander hören. Vor allen Dingen dieses Erleichterte, wenn man dann so ein 56k-Modem hatte und dann macht das manchmal diese boing boing Geräusche irgendwie. Da wusste man schon mal, hier ist Luxus am Start und dann ist ISDN macht ja leider keine Geräusche mehr, die ISDN-Karten. Missing Feature. Genau, also da so glaube ich so eine klassische Laufbahn eines Computer-Internet-Frühinteressierten irgendwie mitgemacht. Aber genau, immer ein bisschen ohne Anschluss, obwohl ich in Berlin war, also eigentlich war der Anschluss nicht weit. Und ich weiß noch, dass ich noch in den späten 90ern auf einen Chaos-Kongress gefahren bin nach Hamburg, kannte niemand, bin hier in den Zug gestiegen.
Späte 90er, das kann ja dann nur 97 gewesen sein.
Genau, das muss einer der Letzten gewesen sein dort. Genau, bin hin mit dem Zug, stand vor dem Gebäude und kannte wirklich niemanden. Und ich hatte auch noch nie so eine große Horde Hacker gesehen und dachte so, die sind alle komisch aus und bin sofort wieder zurück gefahren. Aber das hat den Kongress nicht daheinander genommen. Ich bereue es ein bisschen natürlich im Nachhinein. Wahrscheinlich hätte ich da einen Anschluss gehabt. Ich bin also wieder zurück. Es ist schwierig, da so reinzukommen. Es war nicht, dass jemand gesagt hat, wer bist du denn und hier geht es lang.
Das hätte sich aber sicherlich ergeben.
Genau, es hätte sich sicherlich ergeben, aber ich wusste auch nicht so richtig. Ich bin dann wieder zurück gefahren und so trennten sich die Wege erst mal wieder. Genau, da sind wir dann schon um die Jahrtausendwende herum. Na ja, und dann halt so Internet und so, da gibt es ja nicht mehr viel.
Du bist dann später nochmal auf den Kongress gekommen.
Genau, ich bin dann, als sie dann nach Berlin gekommen sind, die Kongresse, da waren sie ja erst im Haus am Kölnischen Tor, glaube ich. Haus am Kölnischen Park, genau. Schöne Location hat mir damals gefallen, irgendwie. Da war mein Einstand, dass ich auswärts in einem Hackcenter das Licht angemacht habe. Abends.
Das kam bestimmt richtig gut an.
Das war irgendwie halt so zwei Uhr morgens. Ich bin dann rein und so ausversehen mit dem Elbogen-Lichtschalter. Und es kam so Zombie-Trift-auf-Sonnen-Licht-Geräusch. Das war ja auch wirklich so schön von so einer Wendeltreppe nach. Und ich stand halt da oben und es ging so... Ja, und ich schnell wieder ausgeschaltet und dachte mir, ach super, gleich wieder blamiert. An die Kakerlaken gleich wieder unter den Schrank. Ab der Zeit, ab der es dann hier in Berlin war, bin ich jedes Jahr zum Kongress gegangen. Weil es hat immer diese furchtbaren Tage zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester gut gefüllt. Und hab da jetzt auch nie... Bin zwar immer mit einem Freund hin, aber hab da auch nie richtig dran teilgenommen. Ich war einfach nur Besucher, hab mir die Vorträge angeguckt. Enthusiastisch, wie alles geht und hackt. Vor drei Wochen ist es ja leider, gefühlt erst mal leider nach Hamburg gezogen, aber natürlich die Location gut ist, also für den Kongress.
Da warst du auch.
Genau, hat mir als Location gut gefallen. Und ist mit dem ICE eher wie mit der S-Bahn nach Spandau.
Ja, ich denke auch, es hat sich eigentlich nicht viel geändert.
Vorher waren es fünf U-Bahn-Stationen, das war auch nicht schlecht. Das ist ein kleiner Unterschied. Aber der Platz ist natürlich gut.
Ja, aber das hättest du sicherlich auch bereut, wenn du da nicht gewesen wärst.
Ja, ich bin morgens hin, abends zurück. Genau. Ja, Familienvater. Aber auch das geht gut. Also steigst du halt morgens um sieben im Zug und abends 22 Uhr fährst du wieder zurück. Am ersten Tag, ich hab eigentlich hauptsächlich geredet, mich mit den Leuten unterhalten, was man halt so macht auf so einem Kongress.
Das funktioniert ja ganz gut.
Genau. Genau, also das war so meine Geschichte in dieser Richtung. Und gleichzeitig kam dann eben ab einem bestimmten Punkt dieses Studium mit hinzu, was halt so ein bisschen zum Reflektieren geführt hat. Natürlich dann noch mal zu gucken, also ich hab halt Kulturwissenschaft studiert, dann eben zu gucken, was ist das eigentlich hier für eine, das ist ja hier auch eine Kultur. Also sozusagen ein Stückchen auch zurückzutreten und sozusagen nicht nur mitzuschwimmen mit der Welle und das irgendwie zu genießen, sondern eben einen Schritt zurückzugehen, sich das anzugucken, was ist das eigentlich, was bedeutet das, was macht das hier aus, das Ganze. Und diese kulturwissenschaftliche Brille, die wird man leider auch nicht mehr los. Also man fängt an, anständig alles als Kultur anzugucken, das ist ein bisschen eine Krankheit. Macht aber auch Spaß, führt aber auch dazu, dass man sich auch jeden beliebigen Trash angucken kann, weil plötzlich ist alles interessant.
Es ist ja eigentlich auch alles irgendwie ein bisschen Kultur. Also ganz falsch, finde ich den Begriff natürlich.
Kultur sowieso. Kultur ist ja einfach etwas vom Menschen gemachtes sozusagen. Deswegen ist Kulturwissenschaft eben nicht Hochkulturwissenschaft. Das ist ja eine Verwechslung, die auch in der Hacker-Szene meiner Meinung nach noch relativ verbreitet ist. Da gibt es einen sehr tradierten Kulturbegriff. Es gibt zum Beispiel dieses Fernseh-Bashing. Fernsehen ist ja schlecht. Das ist so ein Hochkulturbegriff, der eigentlich auch aus dem 19. Jahrhundert kommt.
Was ist ein Hochkulturbegriff? Wie man das Wort Kultur als solches versteht.
Wir verwenden den Begriff Kultur und meinen aber meistens Hochkultur.
Was meint man, wenn man Hochkultur sagt?
Wenn man Hochkultur sagt, meint man die besondere, wertvolle Kultur, das Anspruchsvolle. Also das den Geist fordernde, die richtige Kultur, die richtige Kunst. RTL ist Unkultur als Gegenbeispiel.
Du würdest sagen, es ist einfach nur Kultur, weil es ist da?
Es ist Kultur, ganz genau. Und ich finde auch generell diesen Hochkulturbegriff schwierig, sozusagen immer kulturell nach unten zu gucken. Das ist auch zum Beispiel ein Grund, warum ich mit Mitch Altmans TV-Begann Probleme habe. Mitch Altman, einer der Hardware-Hacker, hat diese wirklich lustige Fernbedienung gebastelt, mit der man so ziemlich jeden Fernseher ausschalten kann. Mittlerweile gibt es auch Implementationen, die das auf bis zu 100 Meter können, wo gerade eine lustige Diskussion in der C-Base-Medienliste war, ob das eigentlich irgendwie gesundheitsschädigend ist. So Infrarotstrahlung, wenn er bestimmt intensiv ist, ist es natürlich, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Und das ist ja aber wirklich ein Lieblingsobjekt in der Hacker-Szene, da lacht man drüber. Ich finde das schwierig. Ich finde es halt schwierig, anderen Leuten den Fernseher auszuschalten.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall Momente, da ist es sehr unangemessen.
Natürlich.
Also mit einer TV-Begann bewaffnet zu Fußball-Weltmeisterschaftszeiten durch die Straßen zu ziehen, das ist schon eher, naja, also mindestens fragwürdig, wenn nicht gar schon so kulturterroristisch. Aber die Motivation dahinter verstehst du natürlich auch primär, also abgesehen vom Because We Can. Faktor ist natürlich auch eben, glaube ich, das Fernsehen als solches glaube ich, stört die Leute gar nicht so sehr wie die Omnipräsenz des Fernsehens und vor allem diese hohe Weisungsbefugnis, die das Fernsehen irgendwie diese Definitionsmacht, die es hat. Ich glaube, das ist das, was an der Stelle auch am meisten auf Kritik stößt. Und das wird natürlich dann schnell gleichgesetzt mit das Fernsehen. Weil man wehrt sich gegen das Fernsehen nicht, weil man nicht auch mal gerne einen Film gucken würde oder sich von der einen oder anderen Sendung auch unterhalten fühlt. Aber man hat einfach eine Ablehnung gegen dieses, was im Fernsehen gesagt wird, ist die Wahrheit-TM. Und Leute nehmen es auch unkritisch auf. Und ich glaube, an der Stelle tiltet so der Hacker so ein bisschen auf, wenn Leute schnell zu unkritischen Wesen mutieren. Und das zeigt sich natürlich beim Fernsehen ganz stark. Nicht nur beim Fernsehen, auch bei anderen Medien. Aber ich denke, deswegen erntet es so viel Hohn und Spott und Ablehnung.
Ich hab da vielleicht auch nochmal einen besonderen Zugang zu. Nachdem ich wusste, was ich studieren will, und da musste man sich damals jahrzehntelang vorab auf die Warteliste setzen lassen, habe ich noch einen Job angenommen bei Metaproductions. Das war so 1999, 2000. Das ist noch die Filmproduktionsfirma von Ulrich Mayer, der auch heute noch Akte macht. Also so ein klassisches...
War das so ein heißer Stuhl und sowas?
Ja, genau. Der hat heißer Stuhl gemacht. Das hat er noch alles gemacht. War mal Nachrichtensherman bei Sat1. Ist jetzt noch eins dieser wenigen Gesichter bei Sat1, die du seit der Gründung von Sat1 durchdurchdurchgehst. Genau, und der macht immer noch Akte, was erstaunlich ist für Privatfernsehen. Das Format läuft immer noch. Da habe ich ebenfalls gearbeitet in der Online-Redaktion und war auch zuständig für die Recherche von netzbezogenen Themen. Ein bisschen mein Vorgänger, auch nicht direkt, der Vorgänger war Peter Huth. Der Name wird bei einigen triggern. Also der war halt vorher da, genau. Peter Huth. Genau, Peter Huth braucht man eigentlich nicht für, sozusagen, außer seinen Namen. Und ich wollte mir damals Privatfernsehen halt angucken. Also ich wusste damals schon, dass ich Medienkulturwissenschaft studieren will, du schmunzelst. Und hatte halt dieses Angebot und dachte, naja, vielleicht guckst du dir das Privatfernsehen halt mal an, wie es funktioniert. Und hab natürlich meine, also meine Meinung hat sich natürlich schon etwas geändert, weil ich war vorher schon auch sehr stark in dieser, in dieser fernsehkritischen Richtung, ja, in der man so, so das Fernsehen sagt, ach, das Fernsehen, das verblödet und so, ja, das Meinungsmach und so weiter. Wenn du es dann natürlich mal von der anderen Seite siehst, wie es produziert wird und auch diese erschütternden Quotenauswertungen siehst, ja, die die ja teilweise Minuten, wenn nicht sogar Sekundenweise haben, ob die jetzt aussagekräftig sind, ist immer eine andere Frage, stellt sich natürlich auch wieder die Frage nach dem Publikum an einer bestimmten Stelle, ja. Also da fragt sich natürlich auch, warum, warum kann ich denn leider an der Quote ablesen, dass es irgendwie immer funktioniert. Also so Beispiele, die ich einfach mitbekommen hab, ja, es kommt auf ARD geläuft ein Fußballspiel, so von 20 bis 20.15 Uhr, 20.15 Uhr läuft bei dir im Sender deine Sendung. Was machst du? Du willst die ganzen Fußballgucker haben, hauptsächlich angetrunkene Männer. Also bringst du etwas, was hauptsächlich angetrunkene Männer anzieht. Das ist dann zum Beispiel ein Beitrag über Bräunungscreme am Strand. Da lässt sich genug visuelles Material sammeln, einfach um die Leute hängen bleiben zu lassen. Das funktioniert. Ich hab dann diese Quoten aus und ich saß wirklich Haare rauf und da. Das ist nicht nur einseitig dieser Vorwurf, den du machen musst, sondern du musst halt wirklich beiden Seiten vorwerfen. Was mich sozusagen stört, ich finde diesen Vorwurf zu einseitig. Er wird oft immer nur in die eine Richtung formuliert. Das muss auf einer breiteren Ebene diskutiert werden. Es ist eben nicht nur das böse Fernsehen, sondern es ist das Fernsehen und die Zuschauer. Es sind halt beide.
Du meinst, das Fernsehen hackt sich die Zuschauer heran?
Nö, ob es die hackt, das ist schon ein bisschen solche Engineering an der Stelle.
Wie kriege ich jemanden dazu einzuschalten, der eigentlich gar nicht einschalten will? Das geht ja schon so ein bisschen in diese Richtung.
Ja klar, das macht natürlich alles Marketing. Also wie kriege ich jemanden dazu etwas zu tun? Das halte ich auch erstmal nicht für verwerflich. Ich will ja irgendwie ein Produkt annehmen, genauso wie ich auch ein Buch verkaufen will. Aber es funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Genau, jedenfalls habe ich dann noch einen Zwischenstopp beim Fernsehen gemacht und das war auch meine erste Berührung mit dem Thema Technik im Film beziehungsweise im Fernsehen, weil ich dort mitbekommen habe, wie manche Beiträge, die inhaltlich eigentlich interessant gewesen wären, nicht gedreht wurden, weil man einfach nicht wusste, wie man das filmisch darstellen soll. Das war ein unglaublich interessantes Problem. Das fing natürlich auch bei technischen Problemen an. Damals hatte man auch Röhrenmonitore und es war einfach ein Krampf, einen Bildschirm abzufilmen, ohne dass es flimmert. Heute geht's. Damals war das echt...
Stimmt, da brauchte man immer speziell synchronisierte Kameras.
Also hast du gerne mal eine halbe Stunde damit zugebracht, einen Bildschirm, den du abfilmen wolltest und eine Kamera aufeinander abzustimmen.
Weil diese durchlaufende Rasterzeile natürlich dann auch schon so einen Charme für sich hatte.
Wenn dies nur war, genau. Aber das war dann schon der gute Fall, wenn es nur diese Rasterzeile war. Genau, aber da stellte sich halt auch einfach das Problem, dass man einfach nicht wusste, wie kann man ein Internetthema, wie kann man das eigentlich darstellen? Also wie willst du das in einem Beitrag darstellen? Es ist halt nicht Radio, wo du nur erzählst, sondern es ist halt Fernsehen. Fernsehen erfordert Bilder, das ist halt das Medium. Und manche Sachen kannst du halt einfach filmisch nicht bringen. Und das war für mich natürlich interessant, also das ist da einfach eine Erzählform.
Was kannst du dir nicht bringen?
Das fängt schon an bei irgendwelchen Online-Shop-Betrügereien. Natürlich kannst du dann irgendwie Shops und Produkte zeigen, aber wenn es um den eigentlichen Betrugsfall geht, um Fishing, wie zeigst du das jemand eine Passwort-Datenbank geklaut hat und eingebrochen hat? Wenn du das erklärst, was der macht, was willst du denn da zeigen? Weil du hast ja einen Beitrag, also so ein redaktionelles Stück, und sagst dann ja, und dann weiß ich nicht, hat der sich da irgendwie Zugang verschafft über eine Backdoor. Und das war ja damals auch so ein bisschen, weil war ja noch so diese Auswahl von Backorifis und so. Also diese ganzen Backdoors gerne verwendet wurden. Wie zeigst, also wie willst du das wirklich zeigen? Sodass ein Zuschauer auch so da ist und sagt, okay, ja, verstehe ich.
Na ja, ich meine, eine Hintertür ist ja schon an sich ein recht plastischer Begriff. Also da würde mir jetzt spontan eine Menge einfallen.
Ja, genau, das sind ja dann auch diese sogenannten Motto-Bilder. Es gibt Motto-Bilder, das sind halt diese Bilder, in denen du nicht das eigentliche Objekt oder Subjekt des Beitrags zeigst, sondern halt...
Symbolbild.
Genau, Symbolbilder. Da kannst du natürlich eine Hintertür zeigen. Aber das belächeln wir ja natürlich auch gerne bis heute. Wenn wir sowas sehen.
Weiß ich nicht. Es gibt ja diese epische Sendung von Sendung mit der Maus, wie erklären das Internet und so. Die also bis heute gültig irgendwie so IP-Adressen, Routing und DNS irgendwie wunderbar erklärt haben und das irgendwie auch so im Kinderlevel.
Ja, also das stimmt. Das ist auf dem Kinderlevel, wenn es um Erwachsenen geht. Also worüber wir zum Beispiel unglaublich gerne lächeln und da lächle ich auch wirklich gerne mit, ist, wenn in Online-Zeitungsartikeln, die über Hacker sind, Hacker gezeigt werden. Da gab es in letzter Zeit mehrere Bildersammlungen, wo du so Fotosammlungen gesehen hast, wo der Hacker gezeigt wurde, gerne mit Sturmmaske, Schiemaske, einhändig, wichtig ist auch mal auf einer Hand den Laptop und vielleicht in der anderen Hand noch eine Axt. Das sind dann so Motto-Bilder.
Ich finde auch heute gehört noch ein Strohballen dazu.
Genau. Und genau, das ist einerseits lustig, andererseits zeigt aber ein strukturelles Problem. Weil die machen ja was auf dem Bildschirm. Und wie zeigst du das? Wie willst du das zeigen? Und wie zeigst du das für Leute, die nicht in der Materie stecken? Das ist ja immer das Wichtige. Wir haben da ja auch so ein bisschen so eine Brille auf. Also für uns reichen ja schon bestimmte Codes, anhand der wir wissen, worum es geht, worauf das referenziert. Aber jemand, der nicht in dieser Hagerkultur drinsteckt, das ist nochmal ein Großteil der Gesellschaft, wenn du dem eine Geschichte erzählen willst, musst du halt irgendwelche anderen Symbole verwenden. Und da geht es eben auch nicht darum, jetzt nur immer dokumentarisch zu arbeiten. Du kannst halt auch einen Beitrag über ein reales Thema ja eben auch mit Mottobildern unterlegen, aber wie machst du das, dass du dich einerseits nicht lächerlich machst und vielleicht auch nicht zu stark Stereotypen prägst, nicht nur bedienst, sondern auch prägst, das ist ja auch ein spannendes Thema. Und wie manövrierst du dich da drin? Und das ist dann halt das, wo das ganze Thema eigentlich spannend wird an der Stelle.
Wann ist dir denn, ok, du hast jetzt gesagt, dir ist das bewusst geworden anhand dieser konkreten Problematik im Privatfernsehen, ok, wir haben jetzt hier ein Internetthema, wir kriegen das irgendwie nicht dargestellt. Das war ja jetzt dann schon, wann warst du da bei RTL? 1999, Z1. Da war ja das Thema schon relativ weit fortgeschritten. Ist ja nicht so, dass 1999 erst begonnen wurde, irgendwie über Computer zu berichten. Diese Aufgabe, moderne Technologie und auch so virtuelle Zusammenhänge zu beschreiben, muss aber keine wirklich neue Herausforderung. Nicht nur, weil es Computer schon länger gibt. Ich suche jetzt gerade händeringend so ein bisschen nach einem guten Beispiel. Aber so diese Virtualisierung der Welt schreitet ja schon etwas länger voran. Die Dinge werden komplexer. Die Problematiken, die beschrieben werden, werden abstrakter. Sagen wir mal so was wie das Finanzsystem oder so. Ist ja nicht nur, weil sie Computer verwenden, schon schwierig nachzuvollziehen. Sondern weil man natürlich auch in die Begriffswelt eintauchen muss, diese Zusammenhänge, diese Dynamiken von Märkten, Börsen und so weiter. Und gerade bei Finanzen merke ich auch immer wieder diese Hilflosigkeit der Medien. Weil was zeigt man? Dann hat man ja diesen Tummelplatz-Börse, wo sie alle irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Kärtchen schwingen und mit den Fingern schnipsen. Und hallo ich. Was ja in letzter Zeit auch schon wieder ein bisschen verschwunden ist, weil es auch glaube ich bei diesen Börsenplätzen halt auch definitiv anders abgeht. Jetzt sitzen sie halt auch alle nur noch am Bildschirm. Jetzt wird es in gewisser Hinsicht sogar noch schwieriger. Aber so richtig was erzählt, haben wir diese Bilder ja auch nicht. Oder Arbeitslosenzahlen. Ich meine, wie viele Schwenks irgendwie von Eingangspforten von Arbeitsämtern Deutschlands haben wir jetzt in der Tagesschau schon über uns ergehen lassen müssen. Aber niemals hat die Bildsprache uns da wirklich signifikant weitergebracht. Vielleicht ist das einfach auch nur ein Mangel an Infografikaufwand. Also das Problem ist älter und ich frage mich, wann das wirklich angefangen hat. Wie weit muss man da zurück?
Ich glaube, dass das Besondere an dieser Situation ist, du hast natürlich Recht, dass auch arbeitslose Zahlen etwas virtuelles sind, um mal den Begriff dafür zu verwenden. Letztendlich referenzieren sie aber auf etwas sehr Anfassbares, nämlich auf Arbeitslose. Also das heißt sozusagen, also erstens, du verstehst schon, was die Referenz bedeutet vorher. Du weißt, worum es geht und du hast natürlich verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das Ganze zu zeigen.
Ja gut, aber dann nehmen wir was anderes, Staatsschulden. Da wird es schon schwieriger.
Staatsschulden wird ja trotzdem, du hast halt Geld in der Tasche. Aber mit dem Computer hast du halt plötzlich so ein rekursives Problem, dass du im Bildschirm ein Bildschirm hast. Und das ist, glaube ich, sozusagen dieser Bruch, der an der Stelle aufbricht. Du willst in einem Bildschirm über einen Bildschirm erzählen. Und das ist sozusagen das, wo das Medium Bildschirm sich auch anfängt, ja irgendwie wieder selber zu thematisieren. Und deswegen ist das schon ein besonderer Punkt an der Stelle. Deswegen auch die technischen Probleme. Das Abfilmen eines Bildschirms ist halt schwierig, weil es halt Bildschirm und Bildschirm ist. Und das halte ich schon für einen besonderen Moment.
Na gut, am Anfang war es mit den Computern auch einfacher. Da hatte man noch viel Röhren und da war immer alles so schön groß und Lochkarten.
Und laut.
Laut, genau. Es hat auch noch Geräusche gemacht. Diese Sehnsucht nach spezifischen Geräuschen ist ja auch sehr ausgeprägt. Das Problem hat dann wiederum auch schon das Radio. Also wenn dann so über die Hacker berichtet wird, dann muss da halt auch schon mal einer auf der Tastatur klappern und so. Ach ne, lieber doch die andere Tastatur, die klackert besser.
Ja, da gehen dann hier die Apple-Tastaturen wahrscheinlich nicht.
Jaja, ist auch schon irgendwie. Und jetzt Touchscreen, ich sag dir. Gut, aber du hast dich ja vor allem auch, du hast ja auch noch so eine andere Hobbyader, sag ich mal. Das ist, sagen wir mal so, das cineastische Indier, also Filme im Allgemeinen. Warst du schon immer so ein Filmgucker, Kinogänger?
Ich glaube, das ist durchs Studium nochmal verstärkt worden. Es gab da so eine bestimmte Situation, an die ich mich gut erinnern kann. Ich war in einer Vorlesung über Kolonialismus in der ersten Sitzung. Es war so ein bisschen so eine Zwangsveranstaltung. Und irgendwie hatte ich kein Thema, aber irgendwie hat mich Kolonialismus überhaupt gar nicht interessiert, dachte ich zumindest am Anfang. Und der Raum wurde abgedunkelt und Alien 1 wurde gezeigt. Komplett. Und ich saß da mit irgendwie offenem Mund. Ich hatte den irgendwann mal gesehen. Es ging nicht so sehr darum, als ich auch mit offenem Mund da saß, weil ich Alien gesehen habe, aber weil ich in der Vorlesung über Kolonialismus Alien gesehen habe und dachte so, aha. Man kann also auch, also es stellt sich heraus, man kann also auch mit Filmen über Themen reflektieren. Und dann generell natürlich, wenn du die Alien anguckst, sind da natürlich auch eine Menge Referenzen auch wirklich an Kolonialisierung. Also ich glaube der Name des Raumschiffs zum Beispiel und so weiter. Es sind laute Referenzen, die auch absichtlich in diesen Filmen drin sind. Wie das Raumschiff.
Ich will auch gerade. Unheimliche Wesen aus einer fremden Welt.
Ach ja, die Sache mit den deutschen Titeln.
Nostromo hieß das Ding.
Und wenn du jetzt nach Nostromo guckst, wirst du, glaube ich, irgendwie in Kolonisierungsschiffe gegen kommen.
Okay, wir auch mal.
Genau. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Code, an dem du sozusagen noch weiterarbeiten kannst. Ähm, generell genau, war das für mich so ein bisschen der äh, der zündende Moment, äh, zu sagen, ähm, okay, ich, ich, ich kann also Filme, ich muss Filme nicht nur als, äh, als künstlerisches Unterhaltungswerk ansehen, sondern kann sie auch nehmen und in so einem, in so einem Diskurs, so einer Diskussion einfach verwenden, als, als Ausgangspunkt für, äh, für, ja, Betrachtung. Und, äh, plötzlich wurden alle Filme irgendwie interessant, ja. Ähm, ich habe im Studium auch gelernt, immer auf den Hintergrund zu achten, das ist, äh, wirklich eine schöne Sache, wirklich immer, nicht nur die Schauspieler angucken, sondern immer auf dem Hintergrund. Sowas wie, guck dir das Bücherregal an, der Hintergrund, ja. Also, was da für Bücher drinstehen. Da kommen so einige Überraschungen manchmal zutage. Ähm, das können halt wirklich absichtliche Referenzen des Films sein. Das kann auch sein, dass das so, so ein bisschen so irgendwie gar nicht passt. Das ist halt einfach spannend. Ähm, und ich war ja vorher schon an der, so an dieser Hackerkultur-Geschichte interessiert und auch ein bisschen halt so am Rande an dieser Szene mit dran. Und das war dann so dieser Punkt, wo ich dachte, dann guck ich doch jetzt, fang ich mal an rückwärts zu gucken, was gibt's denn eigentlich so für Filme, in denen Hacker sind? Wie sehen die eigentlich aus? Eben auch, weil ich ja das filmische Problem schon mal selbst beim Fernsehen erlebt hatte und hab halt einfach angefangen, erst mal eine Liste zu machen mit lauter Filmen, in denen, sagen wir mal, ein Hacker irgendwie eine wichtige Rolle spielt, weil denen es einen Hack gibt irgendwie. Also Hack jetzt auch im Sinne von Crack wirklich. Also wirklich, dass da irgendwie ein Computersystem penetriert wird, irgendwas passiert da und in so einer Liste sind dann natürlich so die Klassiker drin, so was wie War Games und so was, was man einfach kennt. Dann kann man aber sogar noch weiter zurückgehen. Also ich würde sogar so was wie Welt am Draht damit reinziehen in die Liste.
Das war vielleicht der erste wirkliche Hacker-Film.
Genau, es ist so 73, das ist jetzt so der Rainer Werner Fassbinder. Genau, das ist so der erste Film, den ich in der Liste habe. Das heißt nicht, dass der erste sein muss, aber der markiert so ein bisschen so eine Grenze, finde ich, an der es so, an der dieses Thema so langsam ankommt. Genau, und dann guckt man sich...
Das ist echt eine Empfehlung. Also ich kannte den auch bis vor Kurzem, hatte ich den noch nicht gesehen. Der lief mir dann so ein bisschen über den Weg und war dann echt extrem überrascht. Wie Anfang der 70er Jahre schon dieses ganze Thema der virtuellen Welten etc., was man irgendwie erst so richtig dann in den 80ern eigentlich gerade in der Filmkultur erweckt gesehen hat. Matrix etc., dass sich das da eigentlich schon alles abgespielt hat und das auch in so einer absurden, deutschen Art und Weise Filme zu machen. Auch wenn...
Klaus Löwitz spielt glaube ich mit, genau.
Ja, genau, in einer Hauptrolle Barbara Valentin, Günther Lambrecht, also schon so einige Leute, die man kannte, Ivan Dessny.
Das war für... Ich hab den auch erst...
Heinz Mayer.
Ich hab den auch sozusagen im Zuge meiner Liste geguckt.
Und Rainer Langhans auch.
Rainer Langhans? Echt?
Das ist Kellner.
Wirklich? Das hab ich nicht mitbekommen.
Keine besonders tragende Rolle, aber er ist dabei.
Okay, wenn ich den nächsten Mal gucke, achte ich drauf.
Und Walter Siedlmayr ist Hausmeister. Es ist schon immer wieder erstaunlich, wie sich der Fassbinder alles so herumgeschaut hat.
Es ist jedenfalls, also wenn man Matrix gesehen hat, sollte man auch sich mal Welt am Draht angucken und staunen, was wir eigentlich hier schon 73 so gemacht haben. Das ist schon beeindruckend. Genau. Und das ist auch spannend, wie da halt mit filmischen Mitteln virtuellere Realität umgesetzt wurde, die Übergänge zwischen den Welten. Und genau, jedenfalls ist, wenn du halt anfängst, dir Filme nach einem bestimmten Muster anzugucken, also zu sagen, ich achte einfach auf bestimmte Punkte, kriegst du natürlich dann so eine Linie plötzlich. Du erkennst bestimmte Muster einfach. Also du siehst plötzlich Sachen, die immer wieder auftauchen, Sachen, die in manchen Filmen irgendwie herausstechen, Sachen, die in einem bestimmten Zeitraum besonders auftauchen. Also sowas wie in den 80ern tauchen bestimmte Film, bestimmte Darstellungsformen auf, die aber in den 90ern langsam verschwinden. Und so wurden halt aus der Liste ein paar Dutzend Filme. Das ist halt nicht vollständig, aber es ist, glaube ich, exemplarisch genug, um anhand dessen irgendwie ein bisschen was ablesen zu können. Und das mache ich eigentlich mal mehr oder weniger aktiv bis heute. Als letztes, so der letzte große war vielleicht die Neuverfilmung von The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo und wo auch nochmal eine neue Art der Visualisierung gezeigt wird. Aber darüber können wir vielleicht nachher noch mal in Ruhe reden, was ein eigenes Thema ist. Aber wenn man an so einem Thema dran bleibt, sieht man bestimmte Dinge und natürlich stellt man sich auch die Frage, in welcher Beziehung steht das zur eigentlichen Hackerkultur, also sozusagen zur Arealreferenz, die das hier hat.
Bevor wir da vielleicht noch mehr auf die Filme eingehen, würde mich auch mal auch interessieren, wie jetzt eigentlich dein Blick ist, der ja so ein bisschen ein Blick von außen ist, ein bisschen auch von innen, weil du das ja im Prinzip zumindest in Teilen auch selber an dir selbst erfahren hast. Was verbindest du mit dem Begriff Hacker an der Stelle? Was und Hacker, Kultur, was? Also das ändert in dir hoch, dass du jetzt diese Prototypen, Stereotypen, die man so gemeinhin jetzt kolportiert oder?
Das hängt davon ab, in welchem Kontext ich darüber spreche. Also im filmischen Kontext ist es natürlich, da der Film ja eher Stereotypen bedient ist, ist es in dem Kontext schon eher das, was ich mir da angucke. Ja, eher so der, im positiven Sinne noch der MacGyver in der Serie. Ansonsten verbinde ich nach zehn Jahren Kongressbesuchen mit einem Hacker-Begriff natürlich etwas sehr Differenziertes eben, den dieses Sajases ausgeleitet, diesen kreativen Umgang mit Technik, ausprobieren, bestimmte Grenzen überschreiten, in Dinge hineingucken, hinterfragen. Das kann auch völlig ohne Technik passieren. Es kann ohne Technologie passieren. Es ist eine Technik, also eine Herangehensweise an bestimmte Themen. Ergebnisoffen, Dinge in neue Kontexte packen. Sich nicht damit zufriedenzugeben, für was etwas gemeint ist, sondern zu sagen, vielleicht kann ich das Ganze ja auch neukontextualisieren. Im Technikbegriff heißt es halt, vielleicht löten oder irgendwie mit Software spielen und plötzlich was anderes draus machen. Das ist jetzt aber glaube ich auch kein überraschender Hackerbegriff, also in dem Umfeld. Genau. Das hat sich vielleicht in...
Aber ich meine Hackerkultur, vielleicht brate ich das Wort Kultur auch zu sehr auf. Wir hatten das ja schon, das ist ja eigentlich was ganz Banales, aber was hat sich sozusagen aus diesem Anschein des Individuums eine Kultur entwickelt? Das war mehr so meine Frage.
Also du, es gibt ja bestimmte kulturelle Codes, die einem plakativ wiederbegegnen seien. Es gibt bestimmte Kleidungsfarben, Kleidungsstücke, Musik, die gehört wird, Filme, die geguckt werden, Literatur, die rezipiert wird. Es gibt bestimmte Witze, die man einfach versteht. Man muss nur 42 oder 23 sagen und alle verstehen es. Club Marte wird wirklich bis zum Erbrechen getrunken. Oder eben in den USA dann, weiß ich nicht, Jolt Cola. Also da gibt es dann natürlich regionale Unterschiede.
Wir sind jetzt auch konvertiert.
Zu Jolt Cola?
Nee, zu Club Marte.
Ach so, konvertiert? Ach so, stimmt, der Nick Farr hat das da irgendwie, glaube ich.
Ja, klar, die wollen jetzt auch alle so hip sein wie Deutschland.
Ja, bloß bei uns kriegen jetzt ja alle langsam Flora-Marte, dachte ich irgendwie.
Flora-Power, naja, das ist dann so Second Wave.
Ich bin ja gerade im Moment auf Makkawa, aber das ist noch ein anderes Thema.
Das ist auch ganz toll. Naja, aber die Marte ist schon hier definierend.
Genau, aber da hast du es halt. Also Kultur ist ja kein fester Topf, wenn du nur was reinmachst und einen Deckel draufmachst, sondern das ist ja so ein fließendes, amöbenartiges Ding, an das bestimmte Dinge reinspielen, die vielleicht auch in einer anderen Kultur natürlich im Kontext spielen. Also Club Marte ist auch in anderen Kulturen natürlich spielt das irgendwie eine Rolle, sei es in der Jugendkultur oder mittlerweile. Aber so kannst du natürlich bestimmte Marker sozusagen ausmachen, die so ein unscharfes etwas ausmachen, was du dann Kultur benennen kannst. Und ja, ich meine, du musst ja nur über den Kongress laufen. Also da siehst du ja, da sehen die Leute ja anders aus, als wenn du über einen anderen Kongress siehst. Also so verdichtet sich da etwas. Also gibt es da anscheinend eine kulturelle Codes, die da sehr stark vorherrschen. Obwohl die natürlich in der Hacker-Kultur ja auch immer versucht wird, ich würde sagen, betont versucht wird, sich sehr offen darzustellen. Also eigentlich signalisiert wird, du kannst kommen, wie du willst. Eigentlich achten wir ja nicht darauf, wie du gekleidet bist. Also das soll ja eigentlich nichts ausmachen. Und es gibt ja auch den Anzugträger. Ist natürlich nicht ganz so einfach. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es so offen ist, wie es vielleicht gerne behauptet.
Ich glaube, wenn es ein Anzugträger ist, dann ist es noch okay.
Ich glaube, Fukami ist der Anzugträger.
Nein, Nick Farr ist der Anzugträger.
Ich kenne Fukami, er steht auf dem Kongressfeld.
Nein, Fukami fällt definitiv nicht darunter.
Also es gibt wenig Anzugträger zum Beispiel. Also ist das kein kultureller Code offenbar in der Hacker-Szene.
Ja, das ist auch einfach extrem unpraktisch.
Genau, dieser Praxisbegriff. Darüber gibt es ja diese Hosen mit den vielen Taschen. Genau. Und da sind wir schon mittendrin, in diesem Suchen nach Spuren, die Hacker-Kultur ausmachen. Dann ist immer noch die Frage, warum? Ist die Hose mit den Taschen einfach nur ein praktischer Gegenstand? Und wenn ja, symbolisiert sie nichts oder symbolisiert sie doch was? Weil die Frage ist, ist immer an den Taschen was drin? Ja, ich würde überhaupt nein, sondern natürlich ist sie irgendwann auch einfach ein Zugehörigkeitssymbol. Nun ziehe ich mich nicht morgens an und sage, ich möchte mich jetzt anziehen, damit ich zu einer bestimmten Kultur gehöre, aber es passieren natürlich einfach Dinge.
Kennst du das mit dem Schraubendreher von Vau Holland? Na, Vau hat auch immer diese Latzhose getragen, auch häufig.
Hier hängt ja ein Bild.
Genau, die Latzhose und wahrscheinlich auf dem Foto, wenn man gerade richtig sicher hat, da bestimmt auch so ein Phasenprüfer in der Mitte stecken. Und auf die Frage, warum er immer diesen Phasenprüfer dabei hat, diesen Schraubendreher dabei hat, war seine Antwort.
Es kann ja mal sein, dass ich telefonieren muss.
Das fand ich eine der besten Antworten überhaupt, wo man glaube ich auch gerade diese Einstellung zu Kleidung und ihrer Aufgabe sozusagen auch sehr gut ablesen kann, dass die Funktionalität der kulturelle Ausdruck ist. Generell auch so alles. Taschen sind natürlich praktisch, weil da kann man Sachen vorhalten. Wir haben dieses Allzeitbreit-Ding, so ein bisschen wie Gamma in den Mickey-Maus-Comics, der so alles aus seinem Ländenschutz rausziehen kann. So möchte natürlich auch der Hacker jederzeit die passende Waffe zur Hand haben, um eben welchem Ding auch immer kontrabinden zu können. Aber eher durch Aufschrauben als durch Kaputtmachen.
Genau, ich überlege gerade, ob MacGyver eigentlich Seitentaschen hat. Ich glaube nicht, aber er hat ja auch immer nur wenig Werkzeug.
Er ist eigentlich sehr unpraktisch gekleidet. Jetzt wo du das sagst, merke ich auch, dass das so eine der Dinge sind, die mich glaube ich immer etwas verstört haben. Also er war zwar immer in der Lage, allerlei Zeug, was so rum lag, zu adaptieren und hat von daher ja auch wirklich so eine sehr hackerartige Anmutung. Trotzdem ist er ja gar nicht so ein, ist das nur meine Sichtweise? Ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass er, also er wird zwar irgendwie respektiert so und er ist auch so ein bisschen so immer so das, was man so sagt, mit ich kriege irgendwie alles zusammengebaut, aber in seiner ganzen, wie er so daherkommt, ist er nicht so hackerisch. Ich glaube, wenn er mehr Taschen hätte und mehr mal die Dinge auch immer dabei hätte und nicht nur so findet, dann wäre er schon sehr viel mehr so ein Hackertyp.
Also ich würde den, also er ist im, wenn man über Hackerkultur redet, ist er schon etwas, worüber man reden sollte, glaube ich. Also jetzt eben nicht als Film, sondern als Fernsehbeispiel, weil er natürlich eben ein bisschen dieses Mindset, dieses ich kann Dinge in einen anderen Kontext stellen, ich kann mit ihnen irgendwie basteln. Ich glaube, in der ersten Folge, glaube ich, verschließt er einen Säuretank mit einer Tafel Schokolade. Sagen wir, im Chemieunterricht durften wir das nachstellen, das Experiment damals in der Schule. Wir hatten eine Chemie-Lehrerin, mit der wir McGyver Sachen nachbasteln durften. Das mit der Schokolade hat nicht so gut geklappt. Theoretisch müsste es aber funktionieren. So die Nummer.
So Missbusters-mäßig.
Ja, genau. Den ganzen McGyver-Nummern. Ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz sind es natürlich, aber zum Beispiel auch prägend, diese Fernsehserie, die Kinder auch gesehen. Wenn du die in einem bestimmten Alter siehst, die Serie, wo wir wieder so beibehalten sind. Genau. Kriegst du so mit, so Schokolade in den Tank, alles klar. Du kriegst natürlich eine bestimmte Denkweise einfach vermittelt, wo wir wieder dann eben an diesem Punkt sind, dass natürlich Filme nicht einfach nur darstellen, sondern natürlich auch prägen, in welcher Form auch immer. Also sei es negativ oder zumindest stimulieren. Also ich hab zum Beispiel McGyver als Kind gesehen und das hat natürlich irgendwie, war das schon, das fand man schon irgendwie cool, also diese Herangehensweise. Das ist natürlich interessant, weil Computer spielen kaum eine Rolle bei McGyver. Aber vom Denkweiser-Aspekt her ist das halt wieder interessant, wie das da reinspielt. Es gibt natürlich eine andere Serie hier, ein Trio mit Vierfeusten. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich, wenn wir gerade bei Fernsehen sind.
Ja, auf dieser kleinen Nerd.
Genau, aber hallo mit großer Brille und die hatten so einen sprechenden Roboter.
So ein ganz hässlicher.
Genau, da haben wir richtig dann die Nerd- und Hackerkultur. Dann plötzlich schon relativ früh im Fernsehen. Und natürlich ein krasser Stereotyp, der da vermittelt wird. Die zwei starken Frauenhelden und der kleine Nerd, der aber trotzdem eine wichtige Rolle spielt.
Aber die Frauen nie abkriechen.
Aber die Frauen nehme ich mal an. Das ist wahrscheinlich schon so ein totales Highlight, wenn da am Ende auch mal geküsst wird. Genau, und das ist sozusagen das, wo du dann halt ausgehend von so einem Begriff Hacker, Hackerkultur, dann so ein bisschen dich so langschlängelst. MacGyver ist eben was, was jetzt erstmal von den Worten her nicht verbunden ist mit Hackerkultur, wo du aber eben argumentieren kannst, das spielt aber eine wichtige Rolle. Zum Beispiel dadurch, dass es in einem bestimmten Zeitraum auch ausgestrahlt wurde und bestimmte Generationen auch einfach geprägt hat. Dann ist auch die Frage, warum wurde zu diesem Zeitpunkt diese Serie produziert und so ausgestrahlt? Also du kannst, du versuchst, wenn du etwas kulturwissenschaftlich betrachtest, etwas nicht ideengeschichtlich zu betrachten. Ideengeschichte ist, wenn du sozusagen davon ausgehst, Menschen haben Ideen, dieses so, ah, Heureka, und ersetzen das dann um. Und das ist eigentlich so die Geschichtsschreibung, wie sie so hauptsächlich gelehrt wird, auch in der Schule. Da gibt es so das eine Event und das nächste. Und in der Kulturwissenschaft gehst du eher davon aus, dass es halt so einen zusammenhängenden Kulturbegriff gibt und Dinge nicht einfach zufällig entstehen, sondern dafür auch einfach Rahmenbedingungen da waren. Weil vielleicht gab es auch schon andere Fernsehserien vor MacGyver, die das machen wollten, aber dann nicht in die Produktion geraten sind. Also warum gab es zu diesem Zeitpunkt diese Serie und mit diesem Erfolg auch. Die läuft ja heute noch irgendwo auf, weiß ich nicht, Kabel-1-Klassik oder irgendwie sowas. Und man lächelt dann so ein bisschen, weil man sieht, die zweite Folge MacGyver, das muss ich mal sagen, die synchronisierte deutsche Version heißt Goldbroiler. Keiner weiß warum. Weil Goldbroiler ist ja in der DDR ein Begriff gewesen. Und das wurde irgendwie in Westberlin oder so synchronisiert und du kannst gerne nachgucken, zweite Folge MacGyver Goldbroiler. Bin ich letztens darauf gestoßen, als ich mich mit jemandem über Goldbroiler unterhalten habe.
Im Original The Golden Triangle. Das goldene Dreieck wurde versetzt mit Goldbroiler. In Bruma. Im Kampf gegen skrupellose Drogenhänder. Was hat er dann gemacht? Hat er mit gebratenen Hähnchen um sich geschmisst?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Aber, ja.
Hackerkultur. Ich denke, es wäre jetzt blödsinn zu behaupten, dass sozusagen die Darstellung in den Medien und die Darstellung insbesondere im Film jetzt die Hackerkultur komplett unbrührt gelassen hätte. Das kann man einfach nicht behaupten. Sondern es ist ganz klar, es gibt auch viele Filme, denke ich mal, wo auch die Szene selbst eine Menge dran festmacht. Im Guten wie im Schlechten. Es gibt Filme, da freut man sich, dass es die gab. Und dann gibt es so welche, die eben auch so einerseits diese Stereotypen befördert haben. Also wo, sagen wir mal, das soziale Element des gemeinen Nerds dargestellt wurde in einer Form, ob es nun stimmt oder nicht, das ist immer so eine Sache. Aber die natürlich normative Kraft entwickelt. Und die andererseits aber auch der anderen Gesellschaft ein Drossenario auch vorgestellt hat, was teilweise so in der Szene so gar nicht gesehen wurde. Oder zumindest nicht so aktiv ausgelebt wurde. Wenn man jetzt mal Welt am Draht verlässt, 73. Wo taucht denn der Hacker überhaupt das erste Mal auf? Diesen Begriff gibt es natürlich jetzt bei Fuzzbender noch nicht.
Also da gibt es so zwei Filme, die relativ am Anfang stehen. Das ist Tron 82 und War Games 83. In War Games natürlich, weil der nicht hauptsächlich wie Tron in einer virtuellen Realität spielt, sondern so eine Teenie-Geschichte ist. Ein Junge, spielt irgendwie mit Computern zu Hause rum. Es ist der Film, den ich jetzt bei seinem Einfluss auf die Hacker-Kultur noch als wichtiger ansiedeln würde. Zumal in...
Zumindest für die Außendarstellung.
Für die Außendarstellung, ja. Und aber auch in die Hacker-Szene rein. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das gelesen hab. Was, Bruce Dirling oder so? Es gibt ne... Die Verkaufsstatistiken von 83 zeigen, dass nachdem der Film ins Kino kam, die Modem-Verkäufe in den USA extrem in die Hohe geschossen sind. Weil die sich alle halt zu Weihnachten in Modem gewünscht haben. Das Besondere an War Games ist auch, dass es so ein extremer Erklärbärfilm ist. Also wenn man sich das mal nicht einfach nur so als Film anguckt, sondern anguckt und unter dem Motto, wie wird Hacken dargestellt, merkt man, dass er die ganze Zeit sehr genau erklärt, was er da tut und das sehr langsam abgefilmt ist. Also da sieht man, wie er den Telefonhörer in den Akustikkoppler reinsteckt. Dann gibt es eine, wie er die Diskette reinschiebt, wie er das Programm startet. Da wird sich unglaublich viel Zeit für gelassen. Was auch wichtig ist, glaube ich, in halt 82, 83, weil du ein neues Thema in einem breiten Publikum versuchst zu vermitteln. Heutzutage muss ich nicht mehr erklären, also im Fernsehen und in einem Film lange, was ein Hacker ist.
Man müsste schon eine Menge Zeit darauf verwenden, zu erklären, was in der Kette ist. Die gibt es ja eigentlich nur noch bei Microsoft.
Das heißt, du musstest sozusagen unglaublich viel erzählen. Und Borgins ist interessant, weil es sich unglaublich viel Zeit für ihn lässt, das zu erklären. Der hat so eine Freundin, der Protagonist, die natürlich die Rolle der weiblichen Fragestellerin übernimmt. Sie hat natürlich keine Ahnung und lässt sich dann immer alles erklären.
Ja, auch schon wieder gleich beim nächsten Stereotyp.
Genau, da sind wir natürlich gleich beim nächsten Stereotyp. Aber das wird eben genutzt. Also sozusagen dieses, dass sie fragt, was machst du denn da? Und er dann eben erklärt, das ist ein War-Dialer und der probiert Nummern durch. Und dann, wenn du diesen Film gesehen hast, wusstest du plötzlich so, aha, es gibt irgendwie Modems, da kann man sich einmelden. Und das ist ja technisch nicht, also ok, bis jetzt vielleicht auf diese Nuklear-Ding am Ende, ja, aber es ist ja technisch.
Bis dahin ist es eigentlich relativ solide, das stimmt.
Genau, und dieser War-Dialer, der genommen wird im Film, ist auch der, das ist diese echte War-Dialer, der in den 80ern auch benutzt wurde. Also es ist auch sozusagen, es greift da interessanterweise schon wirklich in diese War-Dialing-Szene so mit rein. Genau, und das heißt, das Interessante ist...
Also War-Dialing muss man vielleicht kurz erläutern, das ist einfach Software, die automatisiert Telefonanrufe durchführt und schaut, ob da halt irgendwelche Karriere sind, ob hinter irgendwelchen Telefonnummern sich überhaupt Datenmodems befinden. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie weit die Software dann ging, ob sie dann auch versucht hat, Verbindungen herzustellen, etc.
Keine Ahnung. Also man hat einfach große Rufnummernblöcke durchprobiert und geguckt, sind da Datenleitungen. Damals, als man noch Telefonnummern anrief mit dem Computer.
Wo sich Leute mit Hallo gemeldet haben, versucht hat, Internet zu machen.
Genau. Und das Besondere an diesem Film ist, dass eben dieses extreme Erklären, dieses Zeigen der Geräte, die werden einfach gezeigt, so wie die aussehen. Und jetzt irgendwas Wichtiges wollte ich noch dazu sagen.
Der Film zeigt natürlich auch das erste Mal so ein und das kann passieren Ding.
Genau.
Also das ist ja überhaupt, glaube ich, die Dimension des Films, sagt ja auch schon der Name. Und dieses Bedrohungsszenario, Teenager im Kinderzimmer, fährt die Raketenköpfe hoch und runter und so. Das hat natürlich dann auch allen irgendwie einen furchtbaren Schrecken eingejagt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen verantwortlich für dieses generelle Hacken ist böse Ding. Das war sicherlich nicht das einzige. Und das hätte jetzt auch alleine nicht gereicht. Aber es war zumindest eine Initialzündung, dieses Memen aufzugreifen und dann eben auch in der Berichterstattung vorzuführen, was ja bis heute anhält. Also wenn irgendwie irgendwo digital irgendwo eingebrochen wurde, dann waren es sozusagen immer Hacker. Weil ja Hacker die Leute sind, die die technischen Voraussetzungen haben, um sowas überhaupt zu machen. Das ist ungefähr so, als würde man sagen, dass alle Bank-Einbrecher, alle Schweißer sind. Weil da weiß man ja, wie man ein Tresor aufkriegt. Und das passt natürlich auch nicht. Aber irgendwie will das heutzutage noch nicht so ganz. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob der Kampf gegen diese Wortdefinition überhaupt noch gewonnen werden kann. Die Hacker-Szene probiert das ja seit langer, langer Zeit, da einerseits ein positiveres Bild entgegenzusetzen und andererseits auch auf diesen schlichten Fakt hinzuweisen, dass es sich bei solchen Leuten primär erst mal um Kriminelle handelt und nicht primär um Hacker. Aber irgendwie scheint dieser Kampf nicht gewonnen werden zu können.
Also ob der Kampf gewonnen werden kann, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so wichtig ist. Vielleicht ist ja so ein fortwährender Kampf auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, das hat natürlich der Szene auch immer geholfen. Das merke ich auch, wenn man früher auch nur vage mit Hacker-Szene verbunden wurde und man taucht halt irgendwo auf und dann so, ah, ja, wirklich, und so Hacker, und so, ja, da muss ich ja jetzt meinen Computer in Sicherheit bringen und so. Kleiner Scherz, wo man dann aber auch schnell merkt, so ein gewisser Grundrespekt natürlich auch gleich da. Sicherlich, das hat auch geholfen.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, bei deinem Stichwort Teenager, was ich noch zu Vorgeheim sagen wollte, das ist auch ein wichtiger Aspekt von dem Film, dass es eben ein Teenager ist, weil der natürlich Jugendliche, die diesen Film gesehen haben, in einem Alter trifft, in dem man ja auch gerade auf der Suche ist nach dem, was man tut. Das ist also dieses Alter, in dem du ja gerne rebellisch bist. Und Hackerkultur ist natürlich etwas, was das sehr gut bedient. Dieses z.B. Nummerndurchbringung, also kein War Games, nur um es kurz zu sagen. Der Protagonist sucht eigentlich ein Computerspiel und hat die Idee, er versucht, sich in die Computerspielfirma einzuhaken, um dieses Spiel zu spielen. Das ist das, was er macht. Er will die Regeln brechen, damit er da ran kann. Das spricht Jugendliche in einem bestimmten Alter auch einfach sehr an. Damit hast du mit diesem Film einen sehr prägenden Einfluss. Weil die werden natürlich älter und manche gehen vielleicht dann auch wirklich in die wirkliche Hacker-Szene. Und sind aber mit diesem Film auch groß geworden. Dass sie bestimmte Stereotypen auch vermittelt bekommen haben, die natürlich vorher wiederum die Hacker-Kultur aufgegriffen haben. Aber halt durch so einen Film, so einmal durch so einen Fleischwolf gehen. Und dadurch dann sozusagen wieder auf die Hacker-Kultur einwirken. Und so hast du dann natürlich so eine beidseitige Abhängigkeit von diesen beiden Szenen.
Ja, WarGames war also auf jeden Fall so die eine Initialzündung. Aber die andere hast du auch genannt, Tron? Und ich weiß noch, ich hab damals Tron gesehen, aber WarGames hab ich glaube ich erst sehr viel später überhaupt zur Kenntnis genommen. Tron wiederum hat sehr viel besser nach innen funktioniert. Also sozusagen die Leute, die ohnehin schon so ein bisschen auf der Spur waren, die haben sich an vielen Stellen wiedergefunden und haben natürlich auch gefeiert, dass da auf einmal ein Film auf die Bühne kam, der auch die eigene Sprache deutlich besser getroffen hat und einfach auch die Begriffswelt ganz anders getroffen hat. Das hat ja allen voran das Bit. Das hat mich gar nicht losgelassen, dass da also einfach ein Bit gab im Film, mit dem man auch noch reden konnte. Das war dann halt nicht sonderlich gesprächig, wie das halt so ist mit Bits. Da kann man nur Ja oder Nein bei raus, aber allein das schon mal so auf den Punkt zu bringen, war eine große Leistung. Was gibt dir Tron?
Na, Tron, ich hab halt überlegt...
Jetzt sollten wir einfach den Plot auch immer noch mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen, weil ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob wirklich jeder jeden Film kennt, weil der schon so ein paar mal hier vorne vorhin notiert, muss auch feststellen, ich kenne auch nicht alle.
Ich weiß auch mal gar nicht, wie doll man spoilen soll, aber Tron... Nicht so viel. Tron... Also erst mal so wichtig, er ist von Disney produziert, ja? Das finde ich spannend an der Stelle, dass also Disney die Firma war, die so einen Film gemacht hat, der bis heute in der Hacker-Szene gefeiert wird. Also der erste ja auf jeden Fall. Ja, was ist die Story? Sagen wir mal, es gibt einen intelligenten Großcomputer, der intern, wie erklärt man es ohne zu spoilen, der intern sozusagen Säuberungsprozesse ausführt, gegen Viren kämpft und so weiter. Und ein Anwender taucht plötzlich in diese virtuelle Welt komplett ein. Der wird sozusagen aufgesogen und ist da drin und ist sozusagen plötzlich Akteur in dieser Auseinandersetzung. So könnte man es vielleicht so abstrakt genug formulieren, dass man noch Lust hat, ihn anzugucken. Und das Besondere an Tron ist diese unglaubliche Bildsprache. Die haben diese virtuelle Welt gezeigt und haben damit eine enorm farbgewaltige dreidimensionale, natürlich nicht 3D, aber eben dreidimensionale Welt erschaffen, die auch heute noch schon beeindruckend aussieht.
Also diese Vektor-Grafik-Computerspiel-Ära der 80er Jahre, wo eben noch keine vollen Flächen gemacht wurden, sondern man in der Lage war. Also Asteroids war ja noch der Klassiker von Vektor-Grafik. Damals gab es ja auch noch Computerspiele auf Vektor-Computern, also die sozusagen gar keine Rasterbildschirme gesteuert haben, sondern die alles wirklich so in so einer Strichzeichnung gemacht haben, indem sie da den Elektronenstrahl entsprechend abgelenkt haben. Und das hat ja schon mal so eine ganz eigene ästhetische Wirkung gehabt. Und die ist dann in Tron halt durchgehend zitiert worden. Ja, ja, sehr schön.
Genau, und da fallen halt einfach, wie du sagst, bestimmte Worte, wie ein Bid und so, die natürlich so ein bestimmtes Bedürfnis der User, das haben. Genau, da gibt es so ein, irgendwie so was wie a guessing is for users oder so. Also da wird dann auch thematisiert, was ist die Rolle des Users, der mündige User, der unmündige User. Und genau, was ist ein Programm? Auch diese plötzliche Personifizierung von Computerkomponenten ist etwas, was einem ja nicht ganz fremd ist. Also der Computer ist ja schon immer auch personifiziert. Der Computer stürzt ab und so weiter. Also das hat es ja auch in unserem Sprachgebrauch schon lange eingezogen. Auch wenn wir natürlich wissen, teilweise was da passiert, trotz dessen personifizieren wir ihn irgendwie. Und da ist es dann eben das Ganze in so eine Bildgewaltsprache umgesetzt. Und zwar ohne jeglichen Anspruch auf Realität. Deswegen fällt es ihm aber auch leichter, ihn anzunehmen. Weil da muss man nicht drüber diskutieren, ob das jetzt realistisch ist oder nicht. Das ist halt ein Märchen, so ein modernes Disney-Märchen in dieser Technowelt. Und deswegen, genau, ist er auch im Gegensatz zu War Games, wo man eben dann drüber diskutieren kann, ist es jetzt realistisch oder nicht, braucht man das Betron halt gar nicht zu machen. Deswegen kann man es einfach annehmen.
Ja, ist klar, dass es nicht realistisch ist. Ja, das waren auf jeden Fall zwei große Schritte, die relativ schnell, Tron war sogar noch vor War Games.
Ja, und dann? Und dann ist mir ein Film über den Weg gelaufen, den kaum jemand kennt. Ich hab bisher erst zwei Leute kennengelernt, die den kennen, und zwar ein Deutscher, mit Ingolf Lück und Rolf Zacher. Peng, du bist tot. Und ich möchte sozusagen allen, die sich mit diesem Thema befassen oder sich dafür interessieren, hackern Filme sehr ans Herz legen, sich Peng, du bist tot anzugucken von 87. Da fallen so Worte wie Datex. Und es sind auch Akustik-Koppler zu sehen. Und es gibt so Szenen, wo man so davor sitzen denkt, so Mensch, ist aber jetzt, also wenn man die Realismus-Latte anlegen will, gar nicht so schlecht geworden. Es gibt auch manche, die sind hanebüchenkaotisch. Und das ist wirklich, ich glaube, einer der Filme, die am meisten die 80er darstellt, die ich so kenne. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es halt ein deutscher Film. Und ist halt erstaunlich, weil den kaum jemand kennt. Und weil er aber bestimmte Dinge zitiert und zeigt, wo man eben heute sagt, ja, das ist gar nicht so schlecht dargestellt. Das Ganze natürlich auch stereotypisch macht eben der Hacker, der Hacker-Junge, der dann zu seiner Mutter sagt, nein, nein, ich bin nicht am Computer, ich ruf jetzt ein Mädchen an, damit die Mutter beruhigt ist. Und die Hacker sind immer so die Solisten, die eigentlich nichts mit anderen Leuten zu tun haben wollen. Aber trotzdem sind da ein paar Elemente drin, die mich überrascht haben. Und der Film sticht so ein bisschen heraus. Und vor allen Dingen auch wieder, weil es natürlich spannend ist, weil es ein deutscher Film ist. Da gibt es aber so ein bisschen so eine Durststrecke. Also wir haben halt in den 70er Jahren eben Welt am Draht. Dann kommen in den 80er Jahren plötzlich diese zwei Hammer, War Games und Tron, so am Anfang. Peng Du bist Tod würde ich jetzt ein bisschen ausklären, weil es jetzt nicht am weltweiten Filmdiskurs teil gehabt hat. Das war halt hier so in Deutschland, obwohl wir in Deutschland natürlich auch eine besondere Geschichte haben. Deswegen ist es spannend, dass der bei uns war. Und dann geht es eigentlich erst in den 90ern weiter. Und dann aber auch wieder richtig. Also dann ist der der nächste Knaller in dem Thema ist dann Sneakers.
Was ist denn die Historie von diesem Peng Du bist Tod?
Peng Du bist Tod ist der böse Mad Scientist, der mit Robotern tötet. Und sozusagen der Hacker muss gegen den bösen Wissenschaftler gehen, der eben die Roboter für seine Zwecke entfremdet. Das ist so im Groben die Story.
Also da ist der Hacker dann sozusagen schon wieder der Befreier und Beschützer.
Genau, Ingolf Lück ist da der junge Hacker, der so ein bisschen in diese Story rein stolpert. Rolf Zacher zum Beispiel ist der Althacker, der nun mal so ganz kurz zu sehen ist, aber auch irgendwie wirklich super kommt in der Szene. Der sozusagen so den Hackersupporter irgendwie. Da gibt es auch die Hacker-Community, das ist halt spannend. Da wird in der Hacker-Community zum Beispiel um Hilfe gebeten, weil es halt irgendwie Gefahr ist, und man sich irgendwie unterstützen muss. Genau, aber das ist so die grobe Story. Ja, sozusagen die Hacker-Community gegen den bösen Technikmissbraucher.
Wie für die Community da dargestellt, das kann ja nun in Deutschland damals, 87, eigentlich nichts anderes gewesen sein als das, was man so gemein übers CCC kreisen kann.
Es gibt eine Szene, bei der Rolf Zacher, im Haus ist jetzt vielleicht schon das Falsche, ich sag mal im Raum, da stehen halt so Schwerlastregale mit Technikkabeln drum und das gibt irgendwie so ratternde Nadel-Drucker-Geräusche und flimmernde Monitore. Das ist einerseits total Stereotyp, aber andererseits denkst du dir, naja, kommt mir auch irgendwie bekannt vor. Genau. Und deswegen war das, mich würde interessieren, wer die beraten hat. Also ich glaube, da wird irgendwer beraten haben bei dem Film.
Das ist, glaube ich, überhaupt immer die Frage. Das kommt man sicherlich nachher auch noch mal zu.
Genau. Also das ist diese Peng Du bist Totnummer. Und wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht ein Film, den ich irgendwie empfehle, weil er halt irgendwie großartig ist oder Hochkultur.
Aber er reflektiert die Hacker-Kultur.
Genau, er reflektiert die Hacker-Kultur. War relativ einflusslos, würde ich sagen. Weil ich glaube, wie gesagt, wenn heute nur zwei Leute den kennen, mit denen ich darüber gesprochen habe, und der eine kennt den nur, weil ein Regisseur kennt, der den Film gemacht hat. Also, ah, ja, der hat ja einen Bekannten von mir gemacht. Aber er ist ein wichtiges Dokument in dieser Zeitlinie auf jeden Fall. Genau, und ein 90er Sneakers.
Das war es jetzt eigentlich schon mit den 80ern.
Das war schon interessant.
Also so viel gab es nicht oder so viel pickst du jetzt nicht raus?
Ich hab in meiner, also ich hab mir wirklich für die 80er, ich guck grad noch, ich hab noch Blade Runner mit drin. 82. Das ist schon schwierig, das als Hacker-Film zu...
Das ist einer für Hacker.
Genau.
Nicht so sehr über Hacker.
Ja.
Da gibt es einige Filme, die sagen wir mal an der Stelle, also ich würde auch noch einen ins Feld führen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den überhaupt auf deiner Liste hast. Das ist Brasil.
Ja, den hab ich, müsste ich eigentlich drin haben.
Mein persönlicher Favorit ohnehin. Ist jetzt nicht so sehr eine Hacker-Geschichte, aber es ist zumindest so der Kampf gegen das totalitäre System. Unter anderem halt auch mit Technik. In dem Film halt einerseits diese absurden Schreibmaschinen-artigen Linsencomputer, mit einem Mini-Bildschirm, der nochmal durch so eine riesige Lupe vergrößert wird. Und wo ja auch die Zugangsberechtigung und die dadurch gewonnene Autorität eine große Rolle spielt. Er erhält ja da Zugang und ist so ein bisschen auch so der findige Typ in seiner Abteilung. Hat erstmal eigentlich mit dem System an sich gar nichts groß vor, sondern gerät einfach in diesen ganzen Strudel durch Liebe. Ja, er will einfach nur eine Information herausfinden über diese Frau, die er gesehen hat und ist vollkommen besessen und versucht eben dem hinterher zu gehen und nutzt einfach seine Möglichkeiten und seinen Einfluss, den er bei seinem Chef hat, weil er immer derjenige ist, der die Dinge richtig hinkriegt und gerät dann auf einmal so in diese Maschine. Dann auch so dieser klassische Bug, der ganz am Anfang des Filmes steht, das kann man gerne spoilern, diese großartige Szene, wo der Typ da an der Behörde irgendwie versucht, diese Fliege, die ihn nervt, irgendwie einzufangen, sie am Ende mit der Fliegenklatsche oder mit einem Telefonbuch oder so was oder einer Zeitung an der Decke zerquetscht, die dann aber nach einer Weile sich die Reste von der Decke lösen, in den Drucker fallen und dort halt einen Fehler im System erzeugen, der ja nur ein falsch geschriebener Buchstabe ist, der aber dann eine kolossale Verwechslung auslöst. Nicht wahr, das Tattel-Battelsystem? Da gibt es den prototypischen Hacker eigentlich nicht, aber trotzdem so eine Rolle, in der sich Hacker ganz gut wiederfinden bzw. auch eine Gesamtszenerie, in der sich Hacker ganz gut wiederfinden.
Ja, also das spielt ein bisschen in diese Argumentation mit rein. Es ist eben natürlich die Frage, was ich jetzt als Hackerfilm auffasse. Also so wie du das erklärst, kann man diesen Film halt locker in so einer Liste aufnehmen. Blade Runner, ja es ist ein Film für Hacker. Es geht ja aber in Blade Runner auch darum, in gewisser Weise Maschinen zu hacken, nämlich den Maschinen die Information zu entlocken, ob sie eine Maschine sind. Also das ist natürlich auch irgendwie eine hackende Tätigkeit. Social Engineering und so. Das ist dann schon auf einer sehr abstrakten Ebene. Auf jeden Fall ist er noch spannender in dem Zeitraum. Aber er ist natürlich nicht so ein Extrembeispiel wie War Games. Also War Games, klar, brauch ich nicht zu erklären. Bei Blade Runner muss ich eben so wie jetzt, muss ich schon ein bisschen länger das Ganze herleiten. Ist aber spannend, dass er halt auch Anfang der 80er, also das ist halt die Blade Runner-Tron War Games-Band innerhalb von zwei Jahren. War sozusagen so eine Hacker-Bombe plötzlich im Kino. Und dann gibt es eben längere Zeit schon eher eine Durststrecke. Das nächste kommt dann halt Anfang der 90er erst, dieser nächste Punkt. Vielleicht hat man auch einfach ein paar Jahre gebraucht, um es auch einfach zu verarbeiten.
Ja, es ist ja auch interessant zu sehen, was die Hacker-Geschichte zu dem Zeitpunkt gemacht hat. Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre war ja, sagen wir mal, der kulturelle Schock, der von der Hacker-Szene ausgegangen ist, im Wesentlichen der Beginn der Homecomputer-Zeit, die vor allem eben von Spielprogrammierung dominiert war. Deswegen taucht das wahrscheinlich in War Games auch so auf als Aufhänger, dass es darum Spiele ging. Und da war ja eigentlich, das ist ja auch sehr schön in dem Buch, von hier Hackers, Heroes of Computer Revolution von Stephen Levy, schön beschrieben, diese drei Jahrzehnte, nicht wahr, so the early Hackers und dann so der letzte Teil, den er beschreibt, also die Hardware-Hacker, hier Vosniak etc. und dann eben so der letzte Teil im 80er-Jahre, eben diese aufkommende Spieleindustrie. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was da reflektiert wurde. Und dann passiert ja auch erstmal gefühlt nicht viel. Also dann gab es zwar so die Home-Computer, da hat sich das dann sozusagen entwickelt, aber es dauerte dann sozusagen bis zur nächsten Revolution, nämlich das Netz, bis irgendwie alle nochmal aufwachten und merkten, oder ist was, das geht nicht weg.
Ja, das tritt, glaube ich, ganz gut. Also in Wargames spielt natürlich Telekommunikation schon eine Rolle, aber...
Aber nicht als Netzgedanke.
Genau, aber nicht als Netz.
Nur so als Zugang.
Also es ist halt das Telefonnetz. Genau, es ist halt das Telefonnetz, aber das Telefonnetz ist da eben kein Netz, in dem Sinne, wie wir es heute begreifen. Genau. Während wir bei Sneakers, wo wir Anfang der 90er sind, nämlich genau an dem Punkt sind, wo das Netz eine Rolle spielt. In Sneakers geht es ja um eine Krypto-Box, die so in der Lage ist, alles zu dechiffrieren und halt dadurch gefährlich ist, weil sie halt auf Dinge zugreifen kann. Also da spielt das nochmal eine viel größere Rolle, weil diese Krypto-Box auf Dinge zugreifen kann. Und das Spannende für mich an Sneakers war, dass sich die Visualisierung der Figur des Hackers total geändert hat. In Wargames war das der jüngere Bell und in Sneakers waren das so ältere Herren. Den Equoid und so. Und die waren alle, ich weiß nicht, also 30 deutlich plus, glaube ich. Oder vielleicht kommst du mir zuvor, aber auf jeden Fall alt.
Robert Redford, Sidney Poitier.
Genau. Die waren da nicht 16. Sondern das waren einfach alles schon gestandene Herren.
Ja, und auch so Professionals.
Genau.
Das war sozusagen das Ganze ja auch schon so ein Richtiges, ein Beruf. Genau, ein Business.
Genau. Und das heißt, da wurde eine ganz andere Geschichte plötzlich erzählt, zehn Jahre später. Also da wurde plötzlich eine Geschichte erzählt von einem Business, von älteren Menschen, die das anscheinend schon länger tun, die da nicht reinwachsen. In Wargames wächst er ja plötzlich rein in das Ganze. Also plötzlich ist er sozusagen wieder Willen, ein Hacker. Vorher will er halt eigentlich nur Computer spielen. Und plötzlich entsteht da so was Großes draus.
Ja, so 20 Jahre später.
Genau.
Derselbe Mensch.
Genau. Und plötzlich ist er älter. Und bietet das als Business an. In Sneakers gibt es aber noch eine schöne Parallele zu Wargames, nämlich wie auch in Sneakers wieder versucht wird, zu erklären. Die haben da ja eher schon so eine Wunschmaschine, die sie da finden. Das ist eben diese Krypto-Box, die alles irgendwie dechiffrieren kann. Das gibt aber eine schöne Szene, in der die rausfinden, was diese Box ist. Weil die haben sozusagen diese Box und sollen die untersuchen, diese Hacker-Gruppe.
Genau.
Und sollen rausfinden, was dieser Chip tut. Die Szene ist aus vielerlei Hinsicht spannend. Also da gibt es den einen Hacker, der an einer Breilzeine, also an so einer Blindenschrift gerät, sitzt. Das ist halt spannend. Plötzlich in so einem Hacker-Film, wenn du sowas drin hast, macht super Geräusche, klingt auch irgendwie toll.
Da klackert es mir, dass man da was zu sehen hat.
Genau. Du hast was zu sehen, denkst du, aha, so macht das ein Blinder. Dann hast du in der Szene auch ein ganz wichtiges Symbol, das uns bis heute eigentlich verfolgt. Das ist der Computerbildschirm, der sich in der Sonnenbrille oder in der Brille widerspiegelt. Also da hat natürlich der Blinder so eine schwarze Brille auf. Das heißt, manchmal wird einfach nur sein Gesicht gezeigt und in seinem Gesicht sozusagen spiegelt sich das Ganze wieder. Und das Spannende ist aber, dass Robert Redford mit seiner Filmgefährtin dort sitzt und es Krabbel spielt. Also die haben sozusagen einen Titel genommen und haben die Vermutung, dass hier einfach nur die Buchstaben umgesetzt wurden, um sozusagen den eigentlichen Begriff zu verschleiern. Und die sitzen also da und tauschen die Buchstaben. Und das ist natürlich was, was ein Publikum versteht. Also ein Publikum weiß, was Krabbel ist und versteht, dass man Buchstaben umstellen kann. Wenn ich jetzt dem Publikum aber irgendwas über Krypto und so erzählen würde, das versteht man nicht so einfach. Aber du kannst plötzlich in einer Hollywood-Produktion mit Krabbel so eine Idee davon zumindest vermitteln, was da eigentlich passiert. Und da gibt es eben diese Szene, da sind immer so Wechselschnitte, während einerseits dieser Chip untersucht wird und so die Spannung steigt und man hört so Rattern. Und man weiß, gleich passiert, gleich passiert. Und gleichzeitig wird es geskrabbelt. Und du kriegst irgendwie ein Gefühl vermittelt, was da so passiert. Und es ist auch so ein bisschen, es ist wirklich eine glatte Hollywood-Produktion. Und Robert Redford und so aber trotzdem schaffen dies, finde ich, in dieser Szene, ein gewisses Gefühl zu vermitteln. Das haben sie also nicht schlecht gemacht. Und deswegen ist so, wegen dieser Einszene, ja, ist dieser Film gut und eben auch in den Neunzigern, wie eben nochmal, man sagt, okay, wir müssen nochmal erklären, was hacken ist, eben mit Skrabbel. Das ist so der Ansatz in dem Film.
Genau.
Interessanter Blick. Ja, da sind wir ja auch bei dieser ganzen Visualisierung des Unsichtbaren. Das ist die große Herausforderung offensichtlich für dieses gesamte Genre.
Und hier halt mit Holzlettern. So einfach Holzletter, die auf dem Tisch stehen.
Ich finde es auch sehr interessant, dass sie da, dass sie einen Spezi haben, der blind ist. Also, dass da auch so transportiert wird, dass man eben auch trotz offensichtlicher Einschränkungen wiederum wunderbare Gaben haben kann, wo einem dann eben auch andere, die diese Einschränkungen nicht haben, einem nichts voraus haben.
Also dadurch, dass der nicht sehen kann, wird, finde ich, in dem Film klargemacht, es ist eine reine Kopfleistung. Hacken ist Kopf. Das ist sozusagen das, was das Ganze transportiert. Hacken findet im Kopf statt. Dieses ganze, diese schicken Visualisierungen und so, sozusagen fallen ja dann da raus, weil der interagiert ja auch nur mit dieser Breihe-Tastatur die ganze Zeit. Und trotzdem ist er derjenige eigentlich, der da ist und dieses Problem löst. Also der diesen Chip hackt. Er ist derjenige, der als Erster versteht, was das Ganze ist.
Jetzt haben wir den ganzen Film schon halb gescrollt.
Genau, aber das Ganze ist sozusagen eine Kopfleistung. Gleichzeitig aber kommt man nicht umhin, es wieder schick darzustellen und ihm diese Brille ins Gesicht zu packen und den Bildschirm wiederum auf seinen Augen laufen zu lassen. Das ist natürlich auch spannend, dass seine Augen durch diesen Bildschirm wieder ersetzt werden. Damit sozusagen die sehenden Zuschauer wiederum verstehen, was er da macht. Also sozusagen in seinem Kopf findet dieser Bildschirm statt. Genau, das war so die Sachen, die ich an Sneakers spannend fand. Und wozu ich noch keine abschließende Antwort habe, ist dadurch, dass da ja ältere Leute im Gegensatz zu Wargames diese Hackerrolle übernehmen, frage ich mich natürlich, inwiefern sich das auf die Identifikationsmöglichkeiten auswirkt. Also in Wargames haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass so Jugendliche sich natürlich damit identifizieren können. Ich nehme an Sneakers ist schon eher weniger identifikationsgeeignet, weil das sind halt einfach Unternehmer.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man sich heute so die Realität der Security-Szene, das Security-Business anschaut, ist das in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon wieder recht zukunftskompatibel gewesen.
Ja, das stimmt. Natürlich spannend, was eigentlich in den 90er-Jahren zu der Zeit für Unternehmungen in dem Umfeld stand. Klar, aus heutiger Sicht ist es natürlich eine Dienstleistung. Also gibt es ja genügend Firmen, die das Ganze anbieten. Genau, es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen. Also wer jetzt sozusagen nach dem Podcast sich Sneakers anguckt, der kann auch ein bisschen darauf achten, es gibt da immer so im Hintergrund schöne Visualisierungen, des bösen Hackers versus guter Hacker. Also da gibt es ja dann sozusagen den großen Antagonisten und den Protagonisten. Und die werden auch durch so bestimmte Sachen im Hintergrund immer so als Schwarz und Weiß dargestellt. Da gibt es so eine Szene, wo so Protagonisten und Antagonisten aufeinandertreffen. Und im Hintergrund sind glaube ich so Skulpturen oder so. So eine weiße Figur und eine schwarze Figur. Also so ein bisschen fast mit dem Holzhammer. Oder so ein bisschen so diesen White-Hat- und Black-Hat-Gedanken. So symbolisiert hast. Ja und dann geht es in den 90ern eigentlich erst mal rasant weiter. Zwei Jahre nach Sneakers kam Disclosure raus, der im Deutschen Enthüllung heißt. Was jetzt erstmal eigentlich kein Hacker-Film ist, aber es spielt im Computernetz eine große Rolle. Also es finden Teile des Films spielen in einer virtuellen Welt. Disclosure heißt es.
Auf Deutsch glaube ich Enthüllung. Das ist ja auch ein interessantes Wort schon mal.
Ja, es ist ja jetzt ein Titel. Ja, klar, das ist ein Hacker-Film. Eigentlich geht es in dem Film um erotische Verwicklung, juristische Verwicklung am Arbeitsplatz. Es findet dann aber so ein Battle statt zwischen Protagonist Michael Douglas und Antagonistin Demi Moore im Cyberspace. Da gibt es schöne Visualisierungen in dem Film, die auch überraschend daherkommen. Michael Douglas zieht in einer Szene den Datenhandschuh an, der uns eine Weile im Film verfolgt hat. Der war mal so ein Liebling in Hollywood. Er zieht Datenhandschuh an und setzt die Brille auf. Das haben wir natürlich nicht nur in dem Film, sondern auch in anderen. Und meiner Meinung nach haben wir es vor allen Dingen eben in den 90ern. Der Datenhandschuh kommt in den 90ern und ist in den 90ern ein Symbol für virtuelle Welten, Hacken, Zukunft. Man musste irgendwie schon das Wort allein reichen, um so Zukunft zu sagen. Ich kann mich erinnern, hier in Berlin gab es auch Cyberlin, da gab es so einen Kaffee, da konnte man irgendwie in virtuellen Welten spielen. Ich glaube, da gab es auch ein Ding, wo man auch so ein Handschuh anziehen konnte. Da gab es natürlich auch reale Artefakte, auf die das Ganze referenzierte. Das Spannende ist jedenfalls, dass der da in diese Welt eintaucht. Wenn man sich so Hackerfilme anguckt, stellt man fest, dass wann immer eine 3D-Welt auftaucht, gibt es sehr oft so einen Hacker-Battle, eins gegen eins. Das wird gerne als filmisches Mittel genommen, dass du eine 3D-nationale Welt aufbaust, damit du einen Kampf zwischen zwei Hackern darstellen kannst. Wie willst du es anders zeigen? Das ist halt schwierig. Wenn man immer eine 3D-Welt hat, kann man schon sagen, da kommt bestimmt noch ein anderer Hacker. Dann gibt es die Auseinandersetzung. Da gibt es eben einen Wettlauf zwischen den beiden.
Whitehead gegen Blackhead.
Genau. Und diesen Datenhandschuh, den haben wir dann, ich werde es jetzt wieder lustig aussprechen, 1995 bei Johnny Mnomic. Du kannst es bestimmt besser aussprechen. Dankeschön.
Also das M spricht man eigentlich nicht.
Genau. Ein guter Freund von mir hat das als Chatnamen. Ich kann es bis heute nicht aussprechen.
Bei mir ja noch zwei andere Filme einfallen, die glaube ich sogar noch kurz vorher...
Mit Datenhandschuh?
Ja, war nicht beim Rasenmeermann. Das war auch so ein ganz furchtbarer, mit dieser ganzen 3D-Optik geradezu fahrlässig umgehender Film, der auch glaube ich von seinem Plot her eher zu vernachlässigen ist.
Aber darum geht es ja nicht. Ja, das weiß ich. Das kann sein, dass sie auch... Aber das dürfte zeitlich auch ungefähr...
Das wäre 92.
Genau.
Und da fing das irgendwie auch nochmal an. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann dieser Datenhandschuh von dem Lanier irgendwie mal vorgestellt wurde. Das war ja also lange Zeit wirklich ein totaler Hype. Wie hieß er noch? Jaron Lanier mit VPL Research. Genau, und der hat diese ganze Virtual Reality-Nummer da irgendwie gebracht. Dieser Datenhandschuh, das hat alle total verrückt gemacht. Also Rasenmäher-Mann, glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob da irgendwie so eine Hacker-Geschichte drin war, aber ich glaube, solche Kämpfe haben sich da auch abgespielt. Bei Johnny Mnemonic war das sehr viel mehr an diesem Cyberpunk-Ding. Das ist ja auch ein Begriff, der hast du noch gar nicht fallen gelassen. Den müsste man glaube ich in dem Zusammenhang auch nochmal irgendwie einbringen, der ja eher aus der Literatur kam und ja eigentlich auch so diesen Widerstandstypen da skizziert hat. So was ja auch stellenweise aufgegriffen wurde. So Schockwellenreiter, etc. So immer so dieses Bild des digitalen Widerstandskämpfers. Oder zumindest, wenn er nicht im Widerstand ist, ist er mindestens ein Einzelkämpfer. Jemand, der sich sozusagen durchwurstet, der irgendwie seine eigenen Wege findet dabei. Vielleicht irgendwas entdeckt und dann einfach das große Böse nebenbei dann halt auch noch gleich mitkassiert. Schockwellenreiter, ist das eigentlich jemals verfilmt worden?
Kann es sein, dass das geplant ist?
Das kann sehr gut sein, dass das geplant ist.
In letzter Zeit war von einigen geplanten Verfilmungen die Rede. Ich weiß nicht, ob Schockwellenreiter dabei war. Oder war das Snowcrush, was verfilmt werden soll? Auf jeden Fall kommen in den nächsten zwei, drei Jahren noch ein, zwei Filme, die sicherlich von der Hacker-Szene sehr kritisch beäugt werden, ob sie die Erwartungen erfüllen. Cyberpunk ist natürlich etwas, was sich bis heute durchzieht. Elemente von dieser Ästhetik findet man in der Hacker-Szene bis heute. Sowohl vom Mindset als auch von so optischen Zitaten finde ich. Das ist nichts, was einem irgendwie fremd vorkommt.
Ich denke, da sind wir auch schnell wieder bei diesem ganzen Genre dystopischer Zukunftsschilderung. Ich denke, das ist das, wo sich der Hacker dann auch immer ganz wohl fühlt, weil das halt auch immer so ein bisschen so diesen Stereotyp des immer bösen Systems, was sich gegen einwendet und was auch durch die Nutzung von Technik versucht, Kontrolle auszuüben, dem man sich dann eben entsprechend durch Fleiß und Witz und Findigkeit dann zu widersetzen hat. Das ist schon auch so etwas, was sich da durch die ganze Filmlandschaft durchzieht. Das ist ja auch bei Brasil so ein Thema.
Matrix.
Genau, aber da sind wir ja noch nicht ganz.
Da sind wir noch nicht, genau.
Du warst eigentlich bei Johnny Mnemonic, der ja sozusagen mit Keanu Reeves dann schon mal so einen ganz wichtigen Einzelpersonendarsteller hervorgebracht hat. Das war der Film, mit dem er so richtig bekannt geworden ist, oder? Gab es da vorher noch was?
Ich schau nochmal.
Ich hab den nicht mehr so gut in Erinnerung. Was ist denn bei dem Film überhaupt so das Wesentliche?
In dem Film, dass er Informationen in seinem Gehirn transportiert und sie raushaben will. Er wird beauftragt, Informationen zu transportieren. Der Deal platzt und er muss diese Informationen raushaben und gleichzeitig soll er aber getötet werden, weil die Informationen halt niemand haben soll. Das ist sozusagen der Kurzplot von dem Film. Was ich kurz dazu sagen kann, was ich bei Filmkultur, also meine Herangehensweise ist es nicht eine eben über Regisseurnamen und Schauspielern. Das ist ja so ein Zugang zur Filmkultur, dass du dir sozusagen diese Produktionsbedingungen und die Personen anguckst und darüber halt so Linien ziehst, wie ein Regisseur sich über eine Weile entwickelt, sondern mich interessiert wirklich nur dieses Artefakt des Films dann. Mir ist egal, was der Regisseur damit sagen wollte, sondern ich halte es für eine gute Herangehensweise bei einem Film, den wirklich nur als Film anzugucken und auch nicht zu gucken, erstmal ist er gut oder schlecht, sondern einfach so, was zeigt er irgendwie? Was sagt er aus Versehen? In was für einem Diskurs ordnet er sich irgendwie ein? Und dann kannst du halt, es gibt in Johnny Nonny gibt es eine schöne Szene, also eigentlich die Hackszene, wo es dann auch so diesen 3D-Battle gibt, und dann am Anfang sagt, ah nee, der Computer, ja? Und ich so, ja, diese Szene kenn ich heutzutage, sag ich vielleicht, ich brauch WLAN, ja? Genau, ich brauch Netz, ja. Aber das ist natürlich ein schönes Quote aus dem Movie. Und der Film, sehr spannend, weil der ist ja wirklich Mitte 90er, aber der ist wirklich so 80er. Deswegen ist er aber in sich geschlossen irgendwie. Also ich hab mal eine Vorlesung besucht, die hieß der Gute Film, und da hat der Professor Lorenz Engel versucht zu erklären, was für ihn ein guter Film ist, und hat das eben nicht so dargelegt, dass ein guter Film ist, einen, den man irgendwie gut findet, der irgendwie geschmackvoll ist, sondern ein guter Film ist einer, der einen Genre auf den Punkt bringt. Also der irgendwie, wo man sagt so, da ist das alles drin, ja, also das bringt irgendwie einen Genre auf den Punkt. Und natürlich sind jetzt so einige der Filme, die wir gesprochen haben, die kann man sozusagen gut oder schlecht finden vom eigenen Geschmack her, aber die sind in sich einfach irgendwie geschlossen und funktionieren einfach. Und wenn es einfach ganz viele Stereotypen sind, die sie versammeln, erfüllen sie aber eine gute Funktion darin, diese vielen Stereotypen mal geballt zu transportieren. Und das ist auch das, woran ich so ein bisschen so einen guten Film festmache. Eben Peng, Du bist Tod ist für mich ein guter Film. In dem Sinne, dass er halt einfach schwer 80er und auch noch so ein bisschen Hackerkultur in Deutschland irgendwie in einem Film vereint. Ich würde ihn aber nicht angucken, weil ich, wenn ich abends einen schönen Film gucken möchte, ja, also aber wenn ich ein bisschen lachen will und das dieses Konstrukt mir angucken will, dann ist er gut. Dann ist er sozusagen ein gutes Artefakt, wo ich froh bin, dass ich das in meiner DVD-Sammlung habe. Das war nicht einfach. Ich musste den früher auf Ebay als VHS schießen.
Naja, nicht so einfach zu finden. Das ist absurd, wie schwer es einem gemacht wird, Filme, die es eigentlich seit Ewigkeiten nicht mehr gibt. Und die es schon seit Ewigkeiten gibt zu kaufen.
Ja, klar. Vor allem so deutsche Filme, wo du Schwierigkeiten hast. Wir sind jetzt im Bereich Mitte der 90er. Es gab noch einen Film mit Sylvester Stallone, der nicht so bekannt ist. Der heißt Assasins. Und da gibt es eine weibliche Hackerin in dem Film. Was natürlich spannend ist, weil bisher sind uns, wenn man mal so zurück schaut, noch nicht viele weibliche Hackerinnen, also Frauen, über den Weg gelaufen. Das ist halt nochmal ein eigenes Thema. Also es gibt halt eben nicht viele Filme. Das ändert sich jetzt so in letzter Zeit ein bisschen. Aber das ist so einer der frühen Filme. Die wird da natürlich sehr Stereotyp dargestellt im Sinne, dass sie rote Haare hat, was so ein gern verwendetes Filmstereotyp für so die exotische, erotische Frau ist. Also so rote Haare ist immer so ein... Genau. Das ist so ein bisschen anders. Die wird als unglaublich selbstständig da dargestellt. Es gibt so eine Szene, wo die im Fahrstuhl steht und da kommt so eine Pelzträgerin rein und guckt sich irgendwie so ein bisschen herablassend nach ihr um, weil sie halt so irgendwie normal aussieht aus unserer Perspektive. Und als die Pelzträgerin rausgeht, hat sie halt hinten so ein Graffiti raufgesprungen. Wo wir schon so... Das ist halt nicht Cyberpunk, der Film, aber wo es wieder so um diesen Widerstand geht. Die kämpft halt so auf allen Fronten und unterstützt dann Sylvester Stallone in seinem Kampf.
Und setzt sich auch sonst eigentlich ganz gut gegen die Männer durch, ne?
Genau, die agiert sehr autark. Trotzdem natürlich, wenn man sich den Film in seiner Gänse anguckt, bedient sie natürlich nachher doch wieder alle Rollen-Klischees. Also natürlich gibt es dann die amoröse Beziehung und Sylvester Stallone. Der Muskelmann ist halt da. Es wird halt noch mal getoppt.
Wozu ist der denn noch da? Wenn es da schon eine Hackerin gibt, wozu braucht man dann noch Sylvester Stallone?
Du brauchst halt einen, der die Waffe bedient.
Am Ende heißt es ja der Killer und die Killer. Assassin's, die Killer auf Deutsch. Hier steht auch das Hacken nicht im Mittelpunkt.
Nein, es steht. Sie ist aber die Nebenrolle. Ja, sie ist schon eine zweite Hauptrolle.
Wie sagt man dazu? Gut, also ist auch eine Hauptrolle.
Nebenrolle plus, nennen wir es mal. Sie ist auf jeden Fall handlungstragend. Dass sie da ist, ist wichtig. Sie ist nicht nur mal drei Minuten im Bild. Sie spielt schon eine wichtige Rolle. Sie spielt eine wichtige Rolle. Und in dem Film sind auch schön Computer zu sehen. Viel Apple, was auch eine interessante Nummer ist. Wann welche Computer eigentlich gezeigt werden. Apple ist generell immer relativ viel vertreten. Also wenn mal echte Computer gezeigt werden, dann ist es Apple in den letzten Jahren auch viel Dell. Und wenn es von Sony Pictures produziert wird, Sony. Genau, aber jedenfalls ist dieser Assassin-Film interessant, weil eben auch eine weibliche Hackerin plötzlich im Mittelpunkt steht. Aber auch wieder dieses Autarke zeigt aber letzten Endes natürlich den beschützten Männerhandel doch Brauch. Aber wir haben da einmal so ein rausragendes Moment. Und es ist eben interessant, weil es ist eigentlich ein Action-Film, also der richtet sich auch an ein bestimmtes Publikum, da wird halt geschossen und getötet und explodiert und so. Und dass in so einem Film so handlungstragend aber eben auch ein Hacker mit aufgenommen wird. Also man hat auch keine Scheu mehr vor diesem Thema. Also es sind nicht mehr nur Filme wie Sneakers oder so, die das wirklich sehr stark in den Mittelpunkt stellen, sondern man traut sich das plötzlich auch sozusagen in andere Plots mit reinzunehmen. Also es ist halt so ein wenig bekannt. Genau, es kommt einfach im Mainstream an. Es gab ja vorher schon 15 Jahre, in denen wir andere Filme schon hatten, die das Thema publik machen konnten, erklären konnten. Und Filme stehen ja nicht für sich alleine, sondern man hat ja irgendwie vorher schon immer andere Filme gesehen. Das ist das Besondere an Filmen, diese gegenseitigen Referenzen. Das heißt, hier kann man halt dann schon einfach einen Hacker auch mit auftreten lassen. Da wird nicht mehr groß erklärt, was die macht. Da wird es eher so gezeigt, sieht halt für damalige Verhältnisse irgendwie cool aus, so ein bisschen Effekte und alles ein bisschen geheimnisvoll. Aber es beginnt so die Zeit, in der Hacker einfach kommen können, ohne lange Erklärungen. Und das Ganze kumuliert eigentlich auch 95 im Film Hackers. Der hat nun auch den Titel, wo schon klar ist, worum es geht. Und Hackers ist ein Film, über den man natürlich vortrefflich streiten kann, ob es ein guter Film oder ein schlechter Film ist. Ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen, es ist ein guter Film in der Definition, die ich vorhin genannt habe, also der viele Sachen auf einen Punkt bringt. Es ist einer der wenigen Filme mit Angelina Jolien, an dem ich lachen konnte. Und sie hat viele Filme gemacht. Und auch viele nerd-affine Filme, oder zumindest auf nerds irgendwie ausgerichtet waren, so Tumbräder und so und auch mal ein paar andere.
Meinst du, das ist so auf nerds?
Na ja, wenn ein Computerspiel so...
Ja gut, aber Nerd- und Computerspiele würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt so gleich in einen Topf werfen.
Ja, gut, du hast recht. Also das zieht zurück, die Aussage.
Also der Tumbräder, der damals mit Brain-Damage war.
Der war hart.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich den überhaupt gesehen habe, aber ich hab so viel bereut.
Na ja, man hat sich den halt angest, weil eine der ersten Computerspiel-Verfilmungen mit großem Traumrahmen. Natürlich ging man so rein und dachte, ich soll mal gucken, was wir draus gemacht haben. Plotless. Genau, jedenfalls Hackers. Es geht halt um wirklich... Also eigentlich alle wichtigen Protagonisten sind Hacker an diesem Film. Und der Film ist wirklich sehr trashig, aber er greift schon bestimmte Sachen aus der Hackers-Szene auf. Zum Beispiel gibt es einen Hackspace, da gibt es so einen Space, der außen so Graffitis hat und wo die sich immer so treffen, um abzuhängen, wo du denkst, hey, Hackspace, das kenn ich doch irgendwie. Und Joltkola spielt irgendwie eine bestimmte Rolle. Und es gibt Zitate wie, das Hacker-Manifesto wird eigentlich vorgetragen in dem Film. Da sitzen so zwei Polizisten, also so zwei Ermittler im Auto, der Alte und der Junge, und der Alte liest das Hacker-Manifesto vor und sagt so, hier, hör mal zu und trägt das so vor. Und dann sagt der Junge, ey, das ist cool. Und dann wird dir halt dieser Generationskonflikt gezeigt. Der Junge sagt, ey, das ist doch großartig. Und dann sagst du, was spinnst du, was soll das denn heißen hier? The Beauty of the Board und so dieser ganze Kram. Und es wird eben auch thematisiert, wie das Verhältnis von Eltern zu Kindern ist. Da fragt die Mutter ihren Sohn, ja, was machst du denn? Und er sagt, ja, ein tägliches TV-Network. Und sagt so, ja, gut, beeil dich mal und geh ins Bett. So, und das ist halt lustig in dem Film, aber ich meine, das haben wir auch schon irgendwie mal alles thematisiert. Also wie ist das Verhältnis eben bei diesen jungen Hackern von den Eltern. Das wird in diesem Film alles so ein bisschen angerissen. Und ich find's einfach lustig. Also man kann einfach viel lachen in dem Film. Und der ist vor allen Dingen der Film, in dem Hacker-Pop endlich geworden ist. Also endlich im Sinne von, der ist darin resultiert. Also in Hackers sind Hacker ein Musikvideo. Es gibt ja auch so eine epische Hacker-Battleszene. Und die ist irgendwie unterlegt, ich glaub, mit Musik von The Prodigy oder so. Hammering the Beats und so. Sieht aus wie ein Musikvideo. Und du sitzt so da und denkst so, ah, das ist aber echt ein Wandel. Und die Hacker fangen in dem Film halt auch an, Sex zu haben. Also es ist so... Also halt filmisch. Also in Wargames ist es ein Teenager, in Sneakers ist es ja eher so eine vergleichsweise ältere Menschen-Romanze dann. Und in Hackers sind wir also wieder ein bisschen bei den Jüngeren. Schule, High School spielt so eine Rolle. Und irgendwie, naja, Angelina Jolie halt. Also da wird dann halt schon so, da spielt diese sexuelle Komponente plötzlich eine Rolle, die halt mit der Mitte der 90er immer wichtiger wird. Also Hacker, man fängt an im Film, Hacker sexuell aufzuladen. Am Anfang waren die halt einfach nur so ein Kuriosum, das man einführen musste. Genau, Nerds halt. Und irgendwann geht's los, dass die halt sexy werden. Also so ist ja auch spannend, was die machen. Und jetzt fangen sie an, irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Lederjacken zu tragen und irgendwie Skateboard zu fahren. Genau, Sonnenbrillen zu tragen, sind halt irgendwie so der Underdog und sind irgendwie cool.
Wobei das erscheint mir dann doch schon sehr, jetzt auch eine Erfindung wiederum der Filmbranche zu sein. Weil das an der Stelle für meinen Geschmack einfach bestimmte wichtige Dinge. Wir haben über Kleidung schon viel geredet. Ich meine, wenn jetzt einer im Club auflaufen würde mit Lederjacke und Sonnenbrillen und sagt, ich bin hier der Cool Hacker, der wäre wahrscheinlich schneller wieder draußen, als er gebraucht hat reinzukommen. Das funktioniert halt irgendwie nicht. Was ich auch immer extrem verstörend fand, das haben wir vielleicht auch noch bei ein paar anderen Filmen, aber so bestimmte Dialoge, dass die Leute, die da so als prototypische Hacker gezeigt werden, die auch so völlig in irgendwas drin sind, dann in Dialogen schnell aggressiv werden, einfach so ein Standardverhalten auf einmal an den Tag legen und so soziale Interaktionen haben, die vielleicht der uneingeweihte Zuschauer in dem Moment einfach so mitnimmt, weil so sind ja Menschen. Nur, dass wir halt wissen, ja, sind sie, ja, aber der Hacker, die Hackerinnen, die sind nicht so, sondern die sind anders. Die haben ganz andere Art und Weise, so eine zwischenmenschliche Kommunikation zu führen. Die würden niemals jemanden so über den Mund fahren, laut werden, gar handgreiflich werden, wo ich eben schon mal so eine latente Verstörung in mir spüre und denke, ach, eigentlich habt ihr nicht genug hingeguckt. Oder vielleicht war es euch auch egal. Oder vielleicht habt ihr das irgendwie nicht abgebildet bekommen oder ihr habt es versucht und festgestellt, dass euer Film dann, so wie ihr es in euch gedacht habt, nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ja, also ich gebe dir erstmal recht, dass oft in den Filmen die Hacker als eher aggressiv dargestellt werden, also zumindest in ihren Reaktionen auf die anderen, oder kompromisslos, könnte man vielleicht auch sagen. Ich habe ja nochmal andere Sicht auf die Hacker-Szene als du. Ich sehe das nicht ganz so, dass es aus der Luft gegriffen ist. Weil es gibt ja in der Hacker-Kultur, die sind diesen einen Grundsatz, beurteile anderen nicht danach, was sie sind, sondern was sie tun. Das versucht sich ja als sehr starke Inklusion darzustellen. Das ist aber gleichzeitig eben auch eine Exklusion, weil es jedem, der nicht Hacker ist, ja abspricht, Teil dieses Besonderen zu sein. Und die Leute, mit denen die Hacker da kommunizieren, also diese Konflikte in den Filmen sind ja oft, dass nicht Hacker auf Hacker trifft und Hacker wirkt ablehnend, weil er eben auf nicht Hacker trifft, der eben nichts tut, der eben nicht Teil der Community ist. Weil wenn du andere danach bewertest, was sie tun und sie nicht Hacker sind, sind sie aus Hacker-Sicht nicht Hacker. Das ist nämlich eine schwierige…
Oder vielleicht sogar nicht wichtig, ja.
Oder vielleicht nicht wichtig. Und deswegen, das ist ein schwieriger Grundsatz. Da gab es auch in letzter Zeit, glaube ich, so ein bisschen in den Blogs wieder so Diskussionen um diese Punkte der Hacker-Ethik, weil die eben, die sind nicht so einfach. Also die sind, wenn man die erstmal liest, denkt man sich so, wow, das ist toll. Beurteile Leute danach nicht, was sie sind, sondern was sie tun. Das klingt gut. Aber wenn du dann nochmal drüber nachdenkst, denkst du, was ist mit den Leuten, die noch nichts tun oder die nichts tun wollen, die aber einfach nur interessiert sind? Wie gehst du mit denen um? Und die sind nach diesem Teil der Hacker-Ethik, schneiden die irgendwie schlecht ab. Und die kriegen dann vielleicht diese Verhaltensweise ab, die du jetzt im Film sozusagen kritisierst. Die aber vielleicht aus einer bestimmten Perspektive vielleicht, na?
Jaja, lass mich das ergänzen. Es gibt natürlich dann auch so eine gewisse autistische Grundhaltung, die ja auch sehr verbreitet ist, besonders bei den Männern. Die, ähm, ja, eine Ablehnung des anderen ist aber auch aus, darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus. Es ist mehr so eine Unfähigkeit der Kommunikation. Ja, die an der Stelle spricht. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht so reinwaschen und sagen, ja, die Hacker sind ja total pießig drauf und reichen in solchen Momenten eher den Joint weiter. Und so, ja, manche tun das natürlich auch. Aber eigentlich ist es eher so eine Unfähigkeit, so ein Gespräch so aggressiv zu führen. Weil es, glaub ich, dem autistisch Veranlagten, und es sind da sehr viele autistisch Veranlagte, man ist auch gar nicht mal negativ. Das ist einfach nur so eine Ausrichtung der eigenen Psyche, die einfach ein anderes Gewicht legt auf bestimmte Dinge. Das sind sehr häufig Leute, die so eine Art der Auseinandersetzung als Stress empfinden. Die gar nicht, die lieber weglaufen, weggucken, die Ohren zu machen und sich auch in ihrem Bildschirm vergraben, anstatt so eine Real-Life-Interaktion durchzuführen, die aufgeladen ist mit Emotionen und mit, na ja, Untertiteln und zwischen den Zeilen lesen und Gesten interpretieren, also Dinge, in denen sie nicht so gut sind, wo es auch alles nicht so klar ist. Es gibt ja auch so diese Liebe zu diesem Digitalen, diese Begeisterung, die auch ich so habe, wenn ich irgendwie bei Tron das Bit sprechen sehe und es sagt Ja und Nein, weil es sagt nicht Jein. Und die ganze Welt ist immer so voll mit diesen ganzen Ja-Abers und Ja-Ins und irgendwie analogen Zwischenwerten. Und man sehen sich ja dann auch immer so nach so einer digitalen Klarheit, so einer direkten Vermittelbarkeit, dieser Traum von Logik, dieser Traum von Nachweisbarkeit, Beweisbarkeit, Entscheidbarkeit auf allen Leveln, digitale Wahlabstimmungssysteme etc. Also da ist ja auch so eine Liebe, die auch in gewisser Hinsicht eine Flucht aus der sozialen Komplikation ist, die wir dann wiederum empfehlen. Häufig dann eben in diesen Dialogen, da fehlt mir dann irgendwie was. Da merke ich, da ist so eine Beobachtung irgendwie nicht bewusst oder unbewusst nicht umgesetzt worden.
Ich lasse es jetzt mal so stehen, dass sozusagen diese Beobachtung, die Frage ist, welche Aufgabe musst du in der Film da erfüllen? Das ist ja keine Dokumentation. Also wir sprechen hier über fiktionale Werke. Und du hast natürlich das Recht einen bestimmten Anspruch an den Film zu haben. Also die erste Frage, die ich stellen würde, ist, sagen wir mal, das stimmt jetzt so, dass sozusagen so ein autist-artiges Verhaltensweise ist und dass sie gar nicht so aggressiv ist. Die Frage ist natürlich, wie kommt es rüber? Also weil jemand, der zum Beispiel kurz angebunden Kommunikation abbürstet, weil er eigentlich Angst davor hat zu kommunizieren, ist die Frage, wie wirkt denn das bei dem anderen? Das kann nämlich bei dem anderen auch aggressiv wirken, obwohl es gar nicht so gemeint ist. Und dann sagt jemand, das macht man so und so. Das kann sozusagen eigentlich sein, Gott, ich will nicht kommunizieren.
Solange das das Verbale nicht verlässt, mag das so sein, nicht selten, ist es ja dann auch wirklich Handgreiflichkeit, Schubsen, etc.
Meinst du im Film?
Ja genau, da wird es dann eben schwierig. Ich wollte das nur mal so... Wir kommen sicherlich gleich noch zu einem Film, wo mir das auch nochmal auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise aufgefallen ist. Aber das lag daran, dass ich einen sehr guten Vergleich hatte.
Ok, dann nochmal kurz, wir waren gerade bei Hackers. Es gibt von Hackers noch zwei Nachfolgefilme, das sind aber glaube ich eher so Franchises. Die heißen auch nicht unbedingt Hackers 2 und 3. Die heißen irgendwie, ich glaube, Antitrust. Das ist ja so ein bisschen so ein Microsoft-Film. Und noch ein, die würde ich jetzt halt nicht in die... Genau, Startup und Antitrust glaube ich, heißt der andere dann.
Die Antitrust heißt am original Startup, die ist ja...
Achso, ist ja auch eine super Übersetzung.
Und der zweite Hackers 2 Operation Takedown. Original nur Takedown.
Kann man sich halt angucken, wenn man sich so mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzt, fand ich jetzt aber nicht... Also die haben jetzt zu diesem Diskurs nicht irgendwie groß noch mal was beigetragen. Genau, wollte ich nur nennen, weil sie dabei sind. Wenn wir jetzt hier so in den 90ern sind, wir sind jetzt also 95, gibt's... Ich lasse übrigens viele Filme aus. Wir gehen jetzt hier nicht durch jeden Hackerfilm durch.
Nein, nein, sondern nur, was dir so exemplarisch...
PIE, 98. Zu PIE muss ich noch eine Story erzählen, weil sie einfach so peinlich ist, dass man sie mindestens einmal erzählt haben muss. Ich arbeite ja auch für MoviePilot. Das ist so ein Filmportal. Und da haben wir halt viele Praktikantinnen und Praktikanten. Und die stellen sich immer vor am Anfang. Und jeder muss immer seine drei Lieblingsfilme nennen. Das ist halt lustig. Du kriegst ja ständig drei Lieblingsfilme. Und darüber kommst du halt auch ins Gespräch und unterhältst dich dann. Und ich hab mich mit einer Praktikantin aus Kanada unterhalten, eben in meinem beschränkten Englisch. Und hab ihr gesagt, was so meine Lieblingsfilme sind. Und sie sagt, ja, mein Lieblingsfilm ist PIE. Und sie guckte mich völlig entgeistert an und sagte PIE. Und ich so, ich meine ja jetzt hier nicht irgendwie American Pie. Genau. No, no PIE. Und bei ihr verfinsterte sich immer so ein bisschen das Gesicht. Und ich so PIE. Und das ging so ein paar Mal hin und her. Und ich so, weißt du, ich glaube, ich kreide bleich vor. Und einfach die Szene verlissen. Ich so, ja klar, PIE. So, genau. Also das war meine, diese Geschichte. Ich weiß jetzt, wie man diesen Film im Englischen ausspricht.
Okay, also wir reden über den Film, der im Englischen PIE heißt.
Genau. Und im deutschen PIE. Was erstmal kein klassischer Hacker-Film ist, im Sinne von es gibt irgendwie Computernetze, es gibt so einen starken Realbezug. Es ist aber ein Film, der in mehrerlei Hinsicht einfach überrascht. Das ist ja so ein Low-Budget-Film gewesen. Ich glaube wirklich, das ist, ich glaube es war 50.000 Dollar, oder es war irgendwie wirklich wenig. Auf jeden Fall war es fast nicht im Millionenbereich, das Budget. Und es ist einer der wenigen Filme, der aus meiner Sicht unglaublich gut das Mindset eines Hackers, also nicht des Hackers, aber eines Hackers zeigt. Da geht es wirklich darum, was geht eigentlich in so einem Kopf vor?
Dieses Suchen nach Lösungen.
Genau, dieses Suchen und dieses Verzweifeln auch. Und der Film schafft es auch noch etwas besser, etwas darzustellen, was mir in 23, auf das wir gleich kommen, nicht so richtig gut rauskommt. Nämlich dieses... Warum? Also in 23... Das ist ja auch 1998, das ist schön, bei beides im selben Jahr. Im 23 geht es ja in diesem Film auch um das Verrücktwerden. Also um das Verzweifeln an Erkenntnissen. Also so wird das in diesem Film dargestellt. Und in Pi schaffen die das aber, das wirklich zu vermitteln. Du kriegst das irgendwie wirklich mit, dieses Eintauchen, während in Pi, während in 23, eher drüber berichtet wird. Also da tauchst du nicht so ein und in Pi hast du die Möglichkeit, da so kurzzeitig mit aufzugehen und zu sagen...
Das ist ja nur Bohrmaschine.
Genau. Wir spoilen jetzt nicht zu viel, wir sagen nur Bohrmaschine. Und man versteht irgendwas an diesem Film. Und in 23 gibt es diesen krassen Moment, obwohl ja auch jemand verzweifelt an Erkenntnissen und Wahrheitssuchungen. Und jetzt kommst du ja vielleicht ins Spiel.
Das ist ja interessant, weil ich finde nämlich, ich teile vollständig, was du sagst. Mit einem anderen Bereich gewinnt wiederum 23 gegenüber Pi, weil es halt jetzt auch wieder dieser absurde Chip... Ich werde immer verrückt, wenn in so einem Film es immer um den Chip geht. Als ob so ein einzelner Chip irgendwie an sich auf einmal so eine magische Superleistung bringen könnte. Genau wie in Sneakers. Man muss dann nur noch fünf Kabel anschließen und dann tut dieser Chip einfach alles Wundersame. Und es gibt dann auch nur einen davon und so weiter, was auch einfach vollkommen Hanebüchen ist. Das muss man jetzt bei Pi, glaube ich, so ein bisschen abziehen, weil auf der anderen Seite dieser Wahnsinn. Und vor allem auch, was spielen sie noch mal am Anfang? Schach? Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht.
Go oder Schach? Eines von beiden. Ein Brettspiel auf jeden. Oder war es sogar Dame? Ich weiß es gar nicht, aber irgendein Brettspiel.
Kann auch sein. Ich weiß es jetzt auch nicht mehr ganz genau. Also auch diese ganze Auseinandersetzung. Ja, mit seinem Lehrer. Ja, so diese Suche nach der Zahl, nach der Herleitung von Pi, dieser Wahnsinn, dass irgendwie alles erklärbar ist, bis man sich irgendwie komplett auflöst in dieser Welt der Erklärung. Und einfach nur noch wahnsinnig.
Und völlig paranoid.
Da ist vollkommen paranoid noch dazu genommen. Also da ist dieser Film wirklich hervorragend. Ich kann den wirklich jedem empfehlen. Das ist auch einer meiner allerliebsten Filme. Weil er einfach so krass ist. Aber er scheitert halt so ein bisschen, weil er einfach so krass ist. Ich bin ein bisschen an diesem Realismus, auch wenn ich diese Ameisen durchsetzten Krabbelgeräte auch alle ganz unglaublich fand. 23 wiederum. Der ja dann eben auch versucht, so eine reale Geschichte nachzuerzählen. Oder zumindest eine neue Geschichte auf Basis einer realen. An der Stelle kann ich dann hier sozusagen auch nochmal auf CRE 100 verweisen. Mit Hans Hübner. Über diese Zeit auch gesprochen habe, weil er da ja auch eine Rolle drin gespielt hat. In dieser ganzen Geschichte, die letztlich zu diesem Film 23 auch führte. Ja, 23 wiederum war sehr gut recherchiert und sehr gut begleitet und beraten. Im Hinblick auf, wie stellen wir das mit den Computern dar?
Genau, ich bin ja jetzt nicht Zeitzeuge. Ich war ja nicht in diesem Umfeld, in dieser Zeit. Aber was ich gesehen habe, es gibt ja auch ein Chaos-Kongress, wird ja auch gezeigt.
Mit Robert Anton Wilson.
Genau, der auch mitspielt, glaube ich.
Ja, mitspielt, der war da. Ganz großartig. Wir haben uns dann mit ihm hinten in den Raum zurückgezogen und irgendwie eingekifft. Das fand ich schon einer der großen Achievements in meinem Leben.
Genau, in 23 ist es erstaunlich gut verfilmt, einfach dieses ganze Thema. Ich hab mich auch mit Hans drüber unterhalten, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es in meinem Podcast war. Hab ihn auch gefragt, wie er denn so als eigentlichen Protagonist diesen Film fand. Er hat auch ähnlich wie du beschrieben, dass er einfach wirklich gut recherchiert ist und wirklich nur unglaublich lustig ist der Wikipedia-Eintrag von Hans dazu, in dem halt steht, dass Hans aus dramaturgischen Gründen zu einer Person zusammengelegt worden ist.
Also er und eine weitere Person wurden zu einer Person zusammengelegt.
Genau, ein sehr schöner Eintrag dazu. Muss ich sehr schmunzeln. Hans meint, die ihm sei das auch ganz lieb gewesen. Genau, aber das ist 23 markiert halt in der, wenn man jetzt so eine deutsche Filmgeschichte aufmacht, Hacker-Filme oder schon Peng Du Bist Tod, das fällt mir auch gerade ein. Da steht es halt in einer interessanten Linie, weil auch Peng Du Bist Tod, das hat jetzt keinen richtigen Realgeschichtsbezug gehabt, aber der war eben auch schon gar nicht so schlecht. Also dass du sagst, da fallen so Stichworte wie Datex und so eine Nummer. Und 23 eben auch, das eben aus der Hacker-Szene kommt, ja, nicht schlecht. So kann man so machen als Film. Da sind bestimmte Grenzen einfach nicht überschritten und man kann sich den angucken. Guter Film. Also es ist einfach ein guter, also auch wieder in dieser Definition, es ist ein guter deutscher Hacker-Film, der in dieser Geschichte halt irgendwie drin vorkommt und auch generell hab ich ihn gern geguckt. Also einfach hab ich gut unterhalten gefilmt. Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist.
Ich hab an der Stelle natürlich sehr schwer, weil ich einfach einen Großteil der Protagonisten persönlich kannte und natürlich ganz andere Bilder dann im Kopf habe. Das betraf natürlich vor allem Karl Koch, der einfach, also es gibt zwar jetzt zwischen dem Hauptdarsteller, wie hieß er noch gleich, Namen, genau, wo ist denn hier der Film? Na, Oro Stiel. Also die haben tatsächlich auch auf den ersten Blick eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit, also ist schon ganz brauchbar gecastet gewesen, von daher, wobei das natürlich dem Zuschauer egal ist. An einem bestimmten Punkt passt es wieder gar nicht und das ist dann eben auch wieder dieses Verhalten, was ich meinte, also so dieses spritzige, quirlige, jugendliche Auftreten, was da an vielen Stellen, dieses hektische, das war nun gar nicht das Ding, sondern er war einfach extrem geprägt von so einer ganz langsamen Art, einer ganz ruhigen Art, die irgendwie überhaupt nicht so quirlig rüber kam. Das kann ich natürlich auch akzeptieren. Ich meine, erstens ist er tot, wer kann das schon so nachfühlen? Außerdem kann das eben auch wirklich sehr langweilig rüberkommen und an der Stelle ist es ja nicht das, was da erzählt werden soll. Ich habe auch mit dem Hans-Christian Schmid kennengelernt. Wir waren ja auf diesen Dreharbeiten, genau diese besagte Szene in Köln, wo dieser Kongress nachgestellt wurde. Das mussten wir uns einfach geben. Das war einfach zu lustig. Ich habe mich dann viel über seine Recherche unterhalten. Wir haben einfach extrem viel Recherche gemacht. Da hat sich dann wirklich ein Buch dazu veröffentlicht mit diesen Rechercheergebnissen. Das ist wahrscheinlich überhaupt eine der besten Aufarbeitungen dieser Geschichte als solcher. Das muss ich gar nicht sagen. Dass sie wirklich mit extrem vielen Protagonisten gesprochen haben und sich dann auch aus dem Umfeld des Clubs jemanden geholt haben, den Scarabeus, der die eben dann auch bei dem ganzen Setup der Computer begleitet hat. Deswegen sind diese ganzen Log-In-Szenen und so weiter, die da drin sind, die sind alle wirklich echt gut. Also das trifft die Sache wirklich sehr gut. Ob das jetzt den Reiz darstellt für den gemeinen Zuschauer, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich kann zumindest sagen, das ist jetzt mal nicht so ein vollkommen wirres Geblinke und diese ganzen 3D-User-Interfaces. Es muss immer maximal futuristisch aussehen und jeder Schritt muss visuell begleitet werden. Diese trockene Ästhetik des Eintippens und der normal leuchtenden Buchstaben, ich finde die auch irgendwie geiler. Ich finde die einfach auch viel magischer, weil sie so reduziert ist. Diese ganzen überladenden Interfaces, die versuchen, tausend Sachen zu erklären, aber am Ende blitzt es und leuchtet es überall, sodass man gar nicht mehr weiß, wo man eigentlich hingucken muss. Und in dem Moment, wo man sich eben wirklich auf ein paar blinkende kleine Mini-Pixel beschränkt, da nimmt man dann die Essenz einfach viel besser mit. Und so ein irgendwie auf so einem grünen Bildschirm nachleuchtender langsamer Blinkekörser, der hat halt auch irgendwie schon was Hypnotisches. Gut, das ist vielleicht jetzt meine Disposition. Aber der Film ist gut. Der Film ist insofern auch sehr interessant gewesen, als dass es auch geschafft hat, die 80er Jahre ganz gut rüber zu bringen. Also das fängt ja dann auch schon so an. Brockdorf, Demonstration, also einfach dieser Zeitgeist, Widerstand, diese Depression zwischen den Atommächten etc. Deutschland in der Mitte, man wusste, wenn es losgeht, wenn wir die ersten dran glauben müssen etc. Das spielte ja alles eine sehr große Rolle, auch für die Geschichte letztlich. Und das ist da gut mit eingearbeitet worden. Von daher war es ein sehr gutes Porträt.
Was ich dazu noch sagen wollte, zu deiner Kritik der Visualisierung, ich finde eben auch spannend, dass es sehr minimalistisch ist in dem Film und man das deswegen gut akzeptieren kann, eben auch einfach richtig sozusagen, also wirklich gut aufbereitet ist. Das wichtige aber an 23 ist auch, dass der Hack als solcher steht nicht wirklich im Handlungsmittelpunkt. Also während andere Filme, über die wir gesprochen haben, eben wirklich längere Hackpassagen sind, in denen wirklich sozusagen in den Computern die Story weiter erzählt wird, wird in 23 sicher eher auf die Figurentwicklung konzentriert. Also da geht es darum, warum treffen die wann welche Entscheidungen und natürlich, dass sie hacken. Aber das ist sozusagen, es geht ja eher um eben ja Porträts von oder ein Portrait.
Auch die Dynamik in der Gruppe mit den einzelnen Spielern.
Genau, deswegen konnte man das da eben auch gut rausziehen an einer Stelle. Und natürlich baut 23 natürlich auch auf eine Filmgeschichte, in der Hacken einfach auch echt schon durchdekliniert wurde. Also du musstest in 23 auch nicht mehr, musst du halt auch nicht mehr erklären, was hacken ist.
So, da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher. Ein Film, der mir, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht, vielleicht übersehe ich jetzt gerade irgendwas. Ich übersehe vielleicht was, aber so grundsätzlich, was ich sehr viel charmanter finden würde, wäre mal wirklich ein Film, der den Hack in den Mittelpunkt stellt. Also der es wirklich schafft irgendwie so. Das ist ja wie so ein, ein guter Hack ist ja wie so ein Geländelauf. Da musst du mal durchfützen und mal über Bäume springen und klettern und du musst permanent deine Disziplin wechseln und andere Ausrüstung an den Start bringen. Dieses Überleben in der Wildnis sozusagen, um dann letztendlich an dein Ziel zu kommen, irgendwie so auf digitalen Wegen und digitalen Pfaden. Und dass man einer schaffen würde, diese Herausforderung für das Individuum, so immer wieder auf Ideen kommen und was finden und das dann auch noch zu visualisieren, das wäre mal ganz spannend.
Also du meinst sozusagen, 90 Minuten MacGyver, aber nur immer die Hack-Szene, ja? Das kann man ja mal zusammenschneiden. Mit Goldbräuler bitte.
Vielleicht kriegt man das mal in so einen digitalen James Bond rein. James Bond Goldbräuler.
Ja, dann haben wir, genau, wir sind gerade so Ende der 90er. Ja, also von Mierau gibt es zu 23 nicht mehr so viel zu sagen, weil da ist einfach wirklich viel zu gesagt worden. Da kann man einfach gucken, den Film ein bisschen was lesen, was darüber geschrieben wurde und das ist sozusagen wenig überraschend ja auch, den hier aufzuführen. Überraschender dafür ist es vielleicht, wenn man sich 99 Office Space rauspickt. Ein Film, der, wenn man ihn nicht gesehen hat, man auf jeden Fall sehen sollte, um so gewisse Memer irgendwie zu verstehen.
Es ist so ein gewisser Moment eine verdammt gute Zeit zu haben.
Genau, also Office Space ist so ein Film, vor allen Dingen auch wenn man in einem Büro arbeitet, der viele Zusammenhänge erklärt. Und in Office Space, der einzige Film mit Jennifer Aniston, den ich den ich er trage, da spielt sie auch mit, und ist der einzige Film, wo ich sie irgendwie gut finde. Die ist ja irgendwie gut in dieser Rolle. Jedenfalls da gibt es die eine Hackszene, wo die spielen in dem Film Superman 3, ich glaube es war Superman 3 nach, da geht es darum, dass sie bei Geldüberweisung diese Rundungsbeträge klauen wollen. Und dafür müssen sie eine Software einspielen. Sie sind sozusagen in so einem Büro, so eine verschworene Gemeinschaft aus drei Mitarbeitern. Und es gibt eben diese eine Szene, wo klar ist, sie müssen jetzt die Software einspielen. Und diese Szene ist unglaublich lustig, weil die ist halt mit so Hip-Hop-Musik unterlegt. Und irgendwie total cool, aber es ist halt auch peinlich. In dem Film ist alles immer ein bisschen peinlich, weil es halt alles in so einer Box-Office, bei diesen ganzen Boxen stattfindet und dann auch total überdreht, weil dann die Mausklicks in dieser Situation mit so Pistolen-Schüssen unterlegt werden. Geht so so Peng, Peng. Und das ist also, hier sind wir schon an dem Punkt, wo der Hack auch schon wieder persifliert wird. Und du kannst ja nur dann etwas persiflieren, wenn du sozusagen schon so kulturelle Referenzen hast, die irgendwie gestreut sind. Also man kann sich schon irgendwie satirisch darüber lustig machen. Und das Ganze passiert halt in diesem Film wirklich lustig. Und das ist natürlich kein Hacker-Film im Sinne von, dass es da die ganze Zeit um Hack geht. Aber es geht um einen Computerbetrug sozusagen, um den sich dieser ganze Film aufbaut. Und der wird einfach sehr lustig visualisiert, so in dieser Nummer. Und es gibt eine unglaubliche, auf YouTube, wenn man nach Office Space sucht, findet man relativ schnell eine Folge, Wer wird Millionär? Das US-Original, wo so einem Typen eine Frage gestellt wird.
Wie heißt das Original?
Wollen Sie mehr Millionär oder so? Ich glaube, so wirklich wörtlich übersetzt. Da gibt es ebenfalls Office Space, da gibt es eine Szene, da sitzt so ein Typ, der auch so im passenden Alter ist, um diesen Film zu kennen. Und er kriegt so eine Frage, in welchem Film, ne genau, in Office Space, auf welchem Film referenzieren. Und der rastet aus, als er schon die Frage sieht, weil er natürlich die Antwort kennt, weil man diesen Film gesehen haben muss. Sehr lustig. Genau, kriegt eine Viertelmillion und flippt total aus, also sehr lustig. Der kriegt die Frage und kann schon nicht mehr sitzen, weil er sagt, das ist der beste Film aller Zeiten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es der beste Film aller Zeiten ist, aber es ist definitiv einer der besten Filme, die man sich überhaupt anschauen kann. Unglaublich lustig, unglaublich kurzweilig und vor allem auch einer der wenigen Filme, da gibt es wirklich echt wenig Filme, die überhaupt nicht langweilig werden, wenn man sie immer wieder guckt. Also man kann den immer wieder schauen und man freut sich geradezu schon darauf, dass jetzt die nächste Szene kommt, weil ich kenne überhaupt wenige Filme, bei denen mir das überhaupt so geht. Das ist definitiv einer davon.
Also es gibt auch, ich glaube, diverse Szenen aus dem Film, halt so memetisch ausgegliedert. Und ich erwische mich öfters dazu, wie ich diese berühmte Szene immer wieder gucke. Didn't you get the memo? Man muss es gucken. Am besten den ganzen Film und die Mood-Buttons. Da sind einfach wirklich viele Sachen drin, die man auch gerne dann so kurz referenzieren kann. Jemand, der den Film gesehen hat, weiß dann Bescheid, worum er spricht. Jedenfalls hier haben wir halt so eine Persiflage und die Flasche schon auf Hacker gucken. Den Typen wir ausrasten.
Der Typ geht total ab.
Man gönnt sie, oder? Man fängt so, okay, nimm die Viertelmillion. Genau, das war die Sache in 99. Vielleicht so ein bisschen überraschend, das Ganze in diese Hacker-Film, in diesen Zeitstrahl sozusagen mit reinzupacken. Ansonsten passieren Ende der 90er natürlich so Filme wie Existenz und Matrix. Also jetzt zwei Schwergewichte sozusagen. Existenz, großes X, großes Z.
Ja, jetzt muss ich gerade mal überlegen. Hackerbezug?
Na ja, da geht es ja um virtuelle Welten, in denen man sich bewegt. Plötzlich auch unklar ist, in welcher Welt man eigentlich sich befindet. Wie bricht man aus, aus diesen virtuellen Welten? Remember?
Ja, ich muss gerade mal kurz nachdenken. David Grudenberg ist ja ein ganz harter Kandidat. Der hat ja auch die krassesten Filme abgeworfen. Kannst du mir das noch mal kurz beschreiben? Was ist bei Existenz? Kurz vorher hat er nämlich diesen Crash abgeliefert. Den fand ich ganz furchtbar. Also, den fand ich furchtbar. Also, was heißt furchtbar? Nee, furchtbar. Also, er ist ja bekannt geworden, vor allem glaube ich, mit Naked Lunch. Das war ja so sein, na Quatsch, die Fliege natürlich. Die Fliege und später kam dann auch Naked Lunch. Den kann ich auch sehr empfehlen. Aber Existenz, das muss ich mir jetzt noch mal erklären.
Also, generell beschäftigt sich der Film mit dem Wechselspiel von, also aus meiner Perspektive, von was ist Virtualität, was ist Realität, in welcher Welt befinde ich mich gerade. In dem Film gibt es so abgefahrene Mensch-Maschinen-Schnittstellen, die sind so Knochen-Gelä-Dinger, die man sich so in den Körper reindrückt, um dann in einer anderen Welt zu sein, in der man agieren kann.
Ja, der ist ja immer so schleimig, dieser Kronenberg.
Genau, aber das ist halt auch das Tolle an dem Film, dass es mal komplett anders visualisiert wird. Es ist eben, ja, da gibt es nicht Chips, die blinken und keine LEDs.
Die tappen auf und fertig.
Genau, da ist so, das ist alles so ein bisschen eklig, aber irgendwie auch toll. Man hat so eine Hassliebe ein bisschen zu dieser Ästhetik, so dass man denkt, ich will es nicht anfassen, aber es sieht toll aus. Und der Film macht einen irgendwann halt auch fertig damit, dass man irgendwann gar nicht mehr weiß, in welcher Realität man eigentlich sich gerade befindet. Und das ist natürlich, und es gibt dann eben sozusagen technischen Missbrauch dieser Systeme. Und das ist natürlich was, was du dann schön in diesem Hacker-Diskurs mit einhauen kannst, der da eben so ein bisschen rauspiekt, weil der eben das Ganze ästhetisch völlig anders aufbereitet. Und auch für ein völlig anderes Publikum da natürlich auch wieder zugänglich macht. Und so ein bisschen alleine dasteht, in einem positiven Sinne. Das ist ein guter Film, ja. Also einfach, weil der was auf den Punkt bringt. Eine bestimmte Ästhetik auf den Punkt. Der vermischt so ein bisschen das Gefühl von Alien mit so einer Hacker-Film-Ästhetik irgendwie.
Ja, ich glaube, ich muss mir den nochmal anschauen. Ich weiß, dass ich den mal gesehen habe, aber...
Ist auf jeden Fall, also das Wöchchen, den kann man sich auch abends mit ein bisschen kommen.
Super, mit Einholmen. Sehr schön, ich mag Einholmen. So, und jetzt kommen wir sozusagen zum... Der Urknall ist nicht das richtige Wort. Aber das ist schon so ein bisschen die Zeitenwende jetzt, ne?
Wir kommen halt zu Matrix. Genau. Wenn ich so in einem Vortrag oder so über Hacker-Film-Regel klammer ich Matrix eigentlich aus, weil irgendwie schon so viel dazu gesagt ist, dass ich das Gefühl hab, ich versuche eher so die...
Die andere Sicht.
Genau, wir sind noch die anderen Sicht. Aber natürlich bringt Matrix viele Sachen auf den Punkt, bei dem wir jetzt schon über Entwicklung gesprochen haben. Also diese Ästhetik, der Underdog, der Lederjackenträger. Dieser Sexappeal des Hackers. Das spielt natürlich eine unglaublich große Rolle. Die sehen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes alle gelackt aus. Und da spielt ja schon an einem relativ frühen Zeitpunkt eine Rolle diese sexuelle Anziehungskraft unter den Akteuren. Dann diese Sonnenbrillen in dem ganzen Film, die man aber natürlich, als diese Filme kamen, die wurden dann auch einfach getragen auf der Straße. Da ist dann natürlich die Frage, warst du erst auf der Straße? Im Film ist es aber glaube ich egal. Aber der hatte schon wirklich eine extreme Massenwirkung. Und der hat halt ganz am Anfang diese allererste Szene, in der Neo da an seinem Rechner hängt. Da schläft der so. Also denkst du, ja so sieht's aus. Also da fängt es auch so an. Und überrascht, und dann geht es natürlich in wirklich ein echtes Science-Fiction, an dem man jetzt hier nicht so einen Realitätsanspruch haben muss, aber er überrascht auch, wenn zum Beispiel Nmap, also der klassische Portscanner Nmap in Matrix verwendet wird. Es gibt auf der Nmap-Seite übrigens eine, also vom Projekt, gibt es eine Seite mit einer Auflistung, in welchen Film Nmap verwendet wird. Das war halt irgendwann, hat man das so erkannt. Mensch, wir können ja wenigstens, das sieht halt irgendwie schick aus, das Tool. Da musst du irgendwie so ein bisschen was anmachen und dann blinkt so ein bisschen was auf der Konsole. Und das ist irgendwie cool. Das versteht zwar kaum ein Zuschauer dann, aber da steht halt irgendwas mit Scan und so. Das kann ja zumindest ein englisch sprechender Zuschauer verstehen. Okay, Scan, das klingt irgendwie gefährlich. Da wird irgendwas untersucht. Das ist natürlich spannend, dass in einem Science-Fiction-Film, dass da dann sozusagen so eine Referenz wieder auf so ein Software-Artifakt aus unserer Zeit sozusagen genommen wird. Und lustig ist natürlich auch, wie dann in den Filmen immer darauf geachtet wird, ja, falsche IP-Adressen zu verwenden. Generell kann man mal gucken, wann immer IP-Adressen immer peinlich darauf geachtet wird.
Das 555 der digitalen Netze.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch irgendwelche Beispiele, wo sie es irgendwie nicht beachtet haben oder irgendwelche IP-Adressen, die mittlerweile irgendwie nicht mehr zu privaten Netzen gehören oder so. Genau, also das ist... Man kann jetzt zu Matrix viel sagen, diese Blue Pill, Red Pill Geschichte und so. Ich glaube schon, dass es natürlich irgendwie stark auch auf Hacker-Szenen Einfluss hatte, weil es natürlich junge Leute nochmal geprägt hat. Auch in dieser Coolness, das Underdog-Sein am Rechner. Aber ich finde ihn jetzt gar nicht so spannend als Untersuchungsobjekt. Weil er ist halt irgendwie durchgekommen.
Ja, aber ohne Zweifel für die Akzeptanz der Hacker-Kultur wiederum ein ganz großer Schritt. Weil hier das erste Mal wirklich... Also bei WarGames war das... Okay, da mag es auf so eine gewisse junge Szene einen Reiz ausgeübt haben, gar keine Frage. Das gilt aber wahrscheinlich für jeden Film, wo Hacker auch nur irgendwie erwähnt werden. Egal, ob sie jetzt so im totalen Mittelpunkt stehen oder nicht. Aber Matrix hat es natürlich total auf die Spitze getreten. Also dieses Bild, nur der Hacker mit seiner Mentalität ist in der Lage, das System zu durchschauen und Kraft seiner Überzeugung auch zu bekämpfen.
Und seiner Gedanken. Wie sich rausstellt, Kraft seiner Gedanken.
Und das ist over the top. Das ist natürlich dann gepaart mit, glaube ich, mit einer, das 21. Jahrhundert einläutenden Gesamtästhetik des Films, mit seinen irren neuen Tricks, die halt, Bullet Time etc., lange Zeit auch heute noch irgendwie definierend sind, ja auch tausendfach kopiert. Also man muss dann immer mal auch nochmal eine Szene haben, wo die dann im Kugelhagel die Wände entlanglaufen etc. Ganz zu schweigen natürlich von, da sind wir wieder bei dem, was du vorhin schon gesagt hast, der Kampf der Systeme im 3D, der ja auch hier sozusagen zur Perfektion gebracht wird. Agent Smith sozusagen als so das Bild des beliebig reproduzierbaren, bösen Wächters gegen halt die wenigen Hacker, die es gibt.
Ja, also es fördert natürlich das Bild, da hast du recht, des Hackers als des Befreiers, also als des Erkennenden. Und man muss da natürlich immer wieder zu sagen...
Des Erlösers, the one.
Ja, voll gut. Also, wir können jetzt... Ja, das ist natürlich... Also, Matrix ist natürlich extrem christlich geprägt. Also, wenn man sich Matrix mal anguckt, nicht als Hacker-Film, sondern als Verbreiter von...
Jesus Reloaded.
Aber hallo, ja. Da gibt es so ein paar Predigungs-Szenen, also wirklich wurde irgendwie... Wo du so denkst... Ja, dann sagt doch einfach Jesus jetzt. Bitte. Also auch so Massen-Szenen, ja. Das war im zweiten oder dritten Teil, wo dann einer oben steht und unten stehen die alle und gucken nach oben. Es gibt auch den, klar, das war doch Matrix, der weiß-bärtige Erbauer, der ist doch auch... Und Matrix spielt da doch eine Rolle. Das ist so auch alles total weiß. Und du denkst, jetzt erschlag dich nicht mit der Ikonografie. Und ich glaube, ich habe auch gelesen, dass Matrix aus diesem Grund auch in irgendwelchen Ländern verboten wurde, weil... Also natürlich in nicht-christlichen Ländern, weil die gesagt haben... Kann ich nachvollziehen insofern, als dass es halt... Ja, der Film ist halt wirklich... Also der präsentiert halt wirklich ein extremes christliches Weltbild. Ob das gut oder schlecht ist, ist eine andere Frage, aber ist schon fast lustig in dem Film.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass er es predigt, aber er spielt auf jeden Fall damit mit den Bildern.
Ja, das ist schon...
Unter dem Aspekt habe ich mir den Film, ehrlich gesagt, noch nie angeschaut. Zumindest hat es bei mir jetzt nicht durchgeschlagen.
Also wenn du noch mal guckst, am besten auch alle drei Teile zusammen, die ergeben dann so eine...
Die anderen zwei Teile sind ja etwas schwieriger.
Ja. Also der erste Teil war natürlich auch der, der geknallt hat irgendwie. Der war so das Neue. Die anderen zwei konnten jetzt auch nicht nochmal das Neue nachliefern. Also man hat ja alles Neue im ersten Teil gesehen, die ganzen neuen Effekte. Und die Story wird ja dann halt noch zu irgendeinem gewissen Ende geführt.
Wir hätten sich eigentlich noch mal ein paar Jahre Zeit lassen sollen.
Ich fand ihn damals auch beeindruckend. Ich weiß, er war damals der Grund, warum ich mir einen DVD-Player gekauft habe. Ich wollte ihn unbedingt zu Hause. Diese Martial Arts Szenen, ich wollte die einfach bis zum Erbrechen gucken. Zeitruppe. War einfach ästhetisch, natürlich großartig für die Zeit. Und hat halt irgendwie, obwohl er eben kein Realhacker-Film ist, es ist eben nicht 23 und das ist auch nicht Peng, du bist tot, das sozusagen in unserer Echtwelt, was auch immer sein soll, spielt, sondern irgendeine abgefahrene Cyberwelt. Trotzdem erzählt er halt was über den Hacker. Diese Nachricht kommt halt irgendwie an beim Publikum. Sei es nur das Außenpublikum, das eben nicht Hacker ist und auch nicht sein will, oder sei es eben der potenzielle Kandidat, der sozusagen dadurch ja auch irgendetwas vermittelt bekommt. Und dadurch mit sich selbst dann vielleicht auch später einbringt in die Hacker-Kultur. Also es gibt ja, ist halt wichtig, es gibt ja immer Nachwuchs die ganze Zeit in diese Kultur. Also immer wieder neu geprägte Leute, die halt immer in ihrer Kindheit von was anderem geprägt wurden. Und wenn du halt mit 14, 16 das erste Mal Matrix gesehen hast, ist halt was anderes, als wenn du mit Welt am Draht aufgewachsen bist. Genau.
Aber die Story ist eigentlich irgendwie, naja, also ich würde nicht sagen, dass es die gleiche Geschichte ist, aber da spoilern wir jetzt mal nicht.
Genau. Aber ja, das war, als ich die Welt am Draht gesehen hab, dachte ich so, hm. Kenn ich doch schon. Kenn ich doch schon, aber im Sequel.
Den zweiten Teil davon hab ich schon gesehen.
Genau. Genau. Ja, also das ist dann halt Jahrtausendwende. 99 Matrix. Und dann sind wir auch schon im Jahr 2000 angekommen. Da ist ein besonderer Film, über den ich gestolpert bin, 2002 Halbe Miete. Den kennt kaum jemand. Das ist ein deutscher Film, der mit Blinkenleids beginnt, auch wenn nur ganz kurz. Der spielt in Berlin und heißt Halbe Miete, weil, das kann man sagen, ohne zuviel zu spoilen, ein Hacker auf der Flucht ist und heimlich in anderen Wohnungen wohnt. Also, dem passiert halt was, weswegen er flüchten muss und schafft es dann halt immer, irgendwie in andere Wohnungen zu kommen und da heimlich zur Untermiete zu wohnen, um nicht entdeckt zu werden. Der Film ist interessant, weil er in Berlin spielt, gleich mit so einer Realitätsreferenz anfängt, mit so einer Kamerafahrt, Blinkenleids zeigt. Und auch in der Anfangsszene gibt es so eine Szene, wo der Hacker an seinem Rechner sitzt und so ja, hier, dann kann ich noch eine Denial-Service-Attacke machen. Dann kannst du in Ruhe das und das machen. Da denkst du, okay, da hat schon jemand beraten und ein paar Stichworte zumindest reingeworfen. Und der Film ist aber ansonsten auch von der, ich fand ihn von der Story her gar nicht so schlecht. Also es macht irgendwie Spaß. Diese Story mit diesem heimlichen Wohnwohnen hat irgendwie Spaß gemacht. Das war auch in irgendeinem Kunstprojekt, ist ja entstanden, ist auf Digital-Kamera gedreht. Genau, und ist halt spannend, weil halt einfach schon so souveränen Hacker-Geschichten mittlerweile erzählt werden. Und eben mit Blinkenlights ja eine kulturelle Referenz ist, die nicht erklärt wird im Film. Die kommt nur ganz am Anfang, ich glaube ein oder zwei Sekunden. Aber es ist halt spannend, wie einfach nur so kurz so na, erinnert ihr euch, das ist sozusagen die Szene, in die wir uns jetzt so ungefähr begeben. Auch wenn der wirklich der klassische Cracker ist in dem Film, der so für Geld irgendwie Systeme in Systeme eindringt. Aber wir sind jetzt hier schon in so einer ganz souveränen Erzählweise. Auf Hacker-Filme, der hat eine paranoide Freundin. Es werden schon so viele Klischee-Stereotypen einfach souverän so auf diesen Film gepappt. Genau. Und der Film ist eben, weil er halt sehr unbekannt ist, würde ich ihn schon empfehlen, weil er halt einfach in diesem Diskurs spannend ist und auch wieder in dieser deutschen Filmgeschichte gut verortet ist. Also Peng Du bist tot, 23 und auch halbe Miete, da erkennt man so ein gewisses Muster an Referenzen aufs reale Hackertum in Deutschland.
Paranoia.
Paranoia. Also die Freundin von dem ist echt paranoid. Das kann man ja schon sagen. Und ungefähr zur selben Zeit in den USA, ich weiß gar nicht, ob 2001 oder 2002, gibt es Swordfish, was im Deutschen dann Passwort Swordfish heißt, warum auch immer sie es nicht einfach eingelassen haben, mit John Travolta. Und da gibt es, also generell dreht es sich um einen Hacker, bzw. es geht um große kriminellen Raub und für den wird ein Hacker benötigt. Und es gibt in dem Film die eine Blojobszene. Die Szene ist, der Hacker wird sozusagen eingeladen, in so einen Club zu kommen und ihm wird gesagt, hier, ich hab gehört, die besten Hacker der Welt können in 60 Minuten 128-Bit-Krypto entschlüsseln und du hast jetzt 60 Sekunden Zeit. Und gleichzeitig kriegt er noch einen Blojobszene und hat eine Pistole am Kopf. Und dieser Film, also die Szene ist natürlich, also absurder geht es nicht mehr. Und ich hab ja nach dem letzten Kongress, da hatte ich den Film auch eine Liste, hab hier einen Mini-Shitstorm bekommen, weil ich diese Szene gezeigt habe. Die ist aber natürlich wichtig in dieser Erzähllinie, die man da aufmachen kann, weil da verdichten sich ganz viele Sachen. Also plötzlich, wenn ich jetzt die ganze Zeit schon über Sexualisierung des Hackers rede, also sozusagen noch deutlicher geht es ja nicht mehr. Und wieder der Liederjackenträger, der coole Typ, der es natürlich schafft in 60 Sekunden, diesen Algorithmus zu quacken. Und wir haben dann hier also schon wirklich Reines.
Vor allem, indem er irgendwie ohne wirklich auf den Bildschirm zu achten, einfach...
Der gibt immer so... Der tippt einfach die ganze Zeit nur was. Genau, da kommen immer so User-Namen. Susadmin, Op, irgendwie steht er die ganze Zeit. Und irgendwann kommt halt Axis Grandeur. Das ist mir auch bei dem Film aufgefallen. Das ist natürlich eine spannende Frage, wie wird dargestellt, dass der Einbruch viel geschlagen ist oder nicht. Immer dieses Rot und Grün. Das ist ja auch lustig. Also wenn ich in irgendeinem System versuche, mich einzuloggen, wird da eigentlich nicht in Rot knallrot, wenn ich mein Passwort einschreibe, ein Zippe irgendwie. Jetzt bist du halt da. Es muss ja filmisch irgendwie eher dargestellt werden. Da würde dieses kurze Wackeln zum Beispiel vom OSX-Bildschirm vielleicht nicht reichen. Also knallt das dann irgendwie. Existinheit und gefährliche Töne. Aber jedenfalls haben wir da halt wirklich so einen klassischen Hollywood-Schinken, der auch wieder halt eher so Action-Movie, vielleicht ein bisschen so ein Heist-Diebes-Movie ist. So verschiedene Richtungen. Und der Hacker ist mittlerweile halt so ein klassischer Protagonist geworden, der da einfach drin vorkommt. Und der ist halt auch so ein bisschen Underdog, auch so ein bisschen einsam. Irgendwie hat er so eine komische Familiengeschichte, deswegen der erpressbar ist. Aber er ist halt auch irgendwie Sexobjekt total in dem Film. Und gleichzeitig eben Matrix, oder fast gleichzeitig eben Matrix, also das ist so, so um die Jahrtausendwende ist das halt extrem dann, diese sexuelle Aufladung von diesen Figuren. Natürlich lustig ist, wenn man jetzt so 2000 auf so ein Hacker-Kongress geht, ja. Und sich denkt so, also hier tragen nicht alle irgendwie die Lederjacken und baggern sich irgendwie die ganze Zeit an, so. Aber das ist halt dann plötzlich ein Bild, das in der Öffentlichkeit, zumindest in diesem Feld vermittelt wird. Natürlich nimmt man diese Filme nicht einfach als Wahrheit, aber auch andere Sachen man nicht als wahrnimmt. Also man weiß, die Explosionen sind zu groß und so. Trotzdem findet natürlich die Transportierung irgendeines Bildes statt. Also was zumindest hängen bleibt, ist, dass er cool ist. Unglaublich cool.
Ich denke, was auch so ein bisschen mit rein spielt, ist das Anerkennen der Gesellschaft, dass das Wissen um Computersysteme und da gut zu sein, schon so eine herausragende Grundfähigkeit ist, die die heutige Welt mit sich bringt. Viele verstehen sich selber als unwissend Anfänger, haben Schwierigkeiten, könnten wahrscheinlich alle sehr viel mehr, als sie denken. Und da ist natürlich so der Hacker als Prototyp des universal Begabten, die Maschine jederzeit Verstehenden, beherrschenden Menschen natürlich ein unglaublich starkes Bild. Man ist auf einmal jemand. Früher war es so der Nerd, der Außenseiter. Ah, hier guck mal, der, der sich mit den Maschinen herumschlagen muss. Mit so was würden wir uns gar nicht beschäftigen, weil wir sind viel zu sehr beschäftigt, die Blondinen über den Strand zu jagen. Und der mit seiner Hornbrille, was für eine lächerliche Type. Und auf einmal hast du eigentlich dieselbe Grundfähigkeit, die aber auf einmal in der Bedeutung so sehr nach oben gestellt wird, weil man einfach sieht, wenn ich diese Fähigkeit habe, dann bin ich nämlich gar nicht mehr der Außenseiter, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, dann ist das so ein bisschen der Schlüssel zum Reichtum, sexy sein, alles auf einmal.
Das ging schon schnell. Genau, diese Allmacht. Und eben ein Zordfisch kann eben der Kuh nicht stattfinden ohne den Hacker. Die haben zwar Waffengewalt und alles, aber sie brauchen eben den Hacker. Ohne den läuft nichts. Genau, ohne den läuft nichts. Und das ist in den letzten Jahren ein typisches Motiv.
Das kennt doch jeder aus seiner Firma. Also ohne eine gute IT-Abteilung. Es ist auch egal, in welchem Bereich du arbeitest. Wenn du das mit dem Computer nicht auf die Reihe kriegst, dann hast du irgendwie keinen Zugang mehr.
Genau, und so ein typischer Film, der wie Zordfisch auch den Hacker als notwendige Komponente für eine Aktion aufgreift, ist zum Beispiel The Italian Job. Den kennen vielleicht viele durch die Minis, die damals immer durch den Film gerast sind die ganze Zeit. Bei Italian Job gibt es eben auch einen Hacker, der helfen muss, damit ein Coup funktioniert. Und dessen Aufgabe ist es, in dem Film Ampeln zu manipulieren. Und diese Ampelmanipulation ist auch etwas, was sich durch viele Filme zieht.
Also wir reden jetzt von dem Film aus 2003.
Genau.
Da gab es wohl mal einen Originalfilm von 1969 sogar noch. Den sehe ich gerade.
Ja, da wird der Hacker wahrscheinlich. Das wäre spannend.
Ja genau. Wollte ich nämlich jetzt auch gerade fragen, aber das weißt du nicht.
Nein, den habe ich nicht auf dem Schirm. Okay. Also in dem von 2003 gibt es einen Hacker, der Ampeln manipuliert. Und diese Ampelmanipulier-Nummer ist etwas, was öfters im Film auftaucht, oder auch so in Fernsehserien wird, das wird das gerne verwendet. Und ich nehme mal an, dass der Ampel-manipulierende Hacker deswegen gerne genommen wird, weil man das versteht. Also auch wenn ich nicht viel von Computern verstehe, kann man sich ja vorstellen, okay, also Ampeln sind vielleicht irgendwie vernetzt. Und das hat eine Auswirkung auf die Echtwelt, wenn man eine Ampel von rot auf grün schaltet. Das ist gut vermittelbar an einem Film. Und deswegen, glaube ich, wird das auch immer wieder auftauchen. Also das ist einfach für einen Film ein gutes Mittel. Ich weiß nicht, ob Ampeln wirklich gehackt werden, aber man hört ja manchmal was. Also wenn dann so Infrarot-Systeme da dran sind.
Ja, ich glaube, die Zahl wird eher steigen in der nächsten Zeit.
Ach so.
Aber es ist interessant. Also hier in der Beschreibung des Originalfilms von 1969 ist auch schon davon die Rede, dass Verkehrschaos in...
Gut, anscheinend muss man sich die 69er-Fassung von The Italian Job mal angucken. Das wirft natürlich meine gesamte Argumentation über einen Haufen.
Load his guerrilla software into the traffic light control computer of the night. Interessant. Schon mit Überwachungskameras und Pipapo.
Das ist natürlich spannend, sich den und den anderen mal anzugucken und die Gemeinsamkeiten und Unterschiede dann in dieser Visualisierung sich mal anzugucken. Also wie wurde in beiden dieses System dargestellt? Also in dem 2003er sind halt so klassische Bildschirme, mehrere nebeneinander. Alles ein bisschen flashy. Da bin ich gespannt, ob es eher so Lötkolben-affin ist in der in der 69er-Version. So richtig viel Hardware, wenn sie noch nicht aufgetischt haben können.
Interessanterweise wird dieser Professor in dem Film tatsächlich von Benny Hill gespielt.
Ein Film, über den wir fast so ein bisschen rüberspringen können, aber weil ihn vielleicht viele nicht kennen, es gab einen Nachfolgefilm von The Net, The Net mit Sandra Bullock. Genau, The Net war natürlich noch 90er, den habe ich jetzt rausgelassen. Da spielt ja so ein bisschen eine Rolle diese Dystopie, was kann die Manipulation meines Profils sozusagen eigentlich für eine Auswirkung für mich haben. Von dem wird es noch ein Sequel von 2006, wo wir wieder eine weibliche Protagonistin haben, die interessanterweise dann auch wirklich so Computer Security Consultant, also so mit Kostümen und Bluse. Also so ganz klischeehaft führt sie Security Audits durch. Ja, das ist natürlich spannend. Da wird es dann einfach auch als so klassischer Beruf wieder, wie in Sneakers, da war das ja noch so ein bisschen fancy als Beruf und hier wird es dann einfach so ganz klar, dass einfach eine Consultant-Tätigkeit, die da ausgeführt wird, und über diese rutscht sie dann halt wieder in eine ähnliche Geschichte rein, wie beim ersten Teil. Spannender ist aber der vierte Teil von Stirb Langsam. Im Deutschen glaube ich Die Hard, nicht Die Hard 4.0, glaube ich heißt der im Deutschen und im Original The Free or Die Hard. In der gibt es ein paar Szenen, ein paar Hack-Szenen und es gibt eine Szene, die einen sehr spannenden Dialog zeigt. Da spielt Bruce Willis den McLane und es gibt eine Szene, da ist Bruce Willis in so einem Keller mit zwei Hackern, also hat so einen jungen Hacker, den er sozusagen beschützt und ist mit dem bei einem älteren Hacker und plötzlich werden sie von der Gegenseite entdeckt und die Gegenseite schaltet sich auf die Webcam auf. Also in diesen Hacker-Keller sozusagen rein und sieht die und die fangen an zu kommunizieren und Bruce Willis will heimlich dem einen Hacker sagen, dass er die bitte zurückverfolgen soll und hält die Webcam zu und sagt, kannst du bitte den zurückverfolgen und daraufhin kommt so ein wirklich extrem arrogantes, das ist eine Webcam, wenn man die Kamera zuhält, kann ich dich noch hören von der anderen Seite. Das ist lustig in dem Film. Aber, und das ist das Interessante, Bruce Willis steht so leicht blutverschmiert davor und hält so eine kurze Rede, in der er klar macht, pass mal auf, du bist zwar der smarte Hacker, aber ich stehe immer noch hier und ich krieg dich. Und das ist so ein bisschen eine Auseinandersetzung zwischen diesem Action-Helden und diesem Hacker und wer natürlich zum Schluss gewinnt, ist der Action-Held. Also es dreht sich auch ein bisschen was an diesem Moment. Also in diesem Film wird sozusagen die Allmacht des Hackers irgendwie entzaubert, weil plötzlich die Action-Figur wieder gewinnt.
Am Ende kriegt er dann doch auf die Fresse.
Genau. Also natürlich beschützt er ja auch einen Hacker. Also es gibt ja mehrere Hacker-Figuren, aber der Antagonist ist plötzlich der Hacker und der Protagonist ist der Action-Held und der auch wirklich, ich glaube, mit einem Auto einen Hubschrauber aus der Luft holt und so. Das ist ja wirklich alles unglaublich in dem Film. Aber irgendwie ist es so ein bisschen so ein gut punktuierter Abrechnungsdialog mit, pass mal auf, du blöder Nerd, wie kommst du mir eigentlich von der Seite? Ich mach dich platt. Das ist eigentlich, das steckt in dieser Szene drin. Deswegen ist dies gut, diese Szene. Weil die halt einen bestimmten Vorwurf auf den Punkt bringt, nämlich ich komm mir nicht so arrogant von der Seite. Ist mir egal, ob man die Webcam noch hört oder nicht, ich krieg dich trotzdem. Und zwar einfach mit Faustgewalt. Und das ist halt, da wird irgendwas geerdet. Also ich fand das spannend sozusagen, dass das so Mitte 2000 plötzlich heißt so, jetzt reicht es aber auch langsam mit dieser Allmacht des Hackers. Und jetzt kommt so diese physische Gewalt schlägt jetzt auch wieder zurück. Das ist ein Filmdiskurs.
Die Zeit ist jetzt vorbei, wir sind nicht mehr cool. Die Actionhelden können uns wieder was.
Na ja, du musst ja, filmische Geschichte muss sich ja immer weiterentwickeln. Du kannst ja nicht immer dieselbe Geschichte erzählen. Und ich glaube schon, dass das so in den 2000er Jahren irgendwann der Punkt kommt, wo klar ist, wir haben jetzt diese Geschichte auserzählt aus Matrix, die in Matrix halt auf den Punkt kommt, die Allmacht der Gedanken und irgendwie kommt und jetzt gibt's auf die Mütze, Jungs. Jetzt reist euch mal zusammen, jetzt kommt wieder die alte Generation. Und das ist ja, Bruce Willis ist halt auch der Älteste von allen in diesem Raum. Er ist wirklich so dieses, also dieses Wrack ist er in dem Augenblick und trotzdem wird er halt gewinnen. Und man weiß vorher, er macht sie fertig. Und dann gibt es 2008 und das kennen auch relativ wenige War Games 2. Es gab nämlich ein Sequel zu War Games. Ich nehme mal an, Direct to DVD. Ich weiß nicht, ob der jemals im Kino gelaufen ist. Wenn nicht, aus gutem Grund. Das ist wirklich schwer zu ertragen, aber als Kulturwissenschaftler guckt man sich ja sowas gerne an. Was spannend ist an dem Film?
Ihr seid komplett schmerzfrei.
Na, ich hab durch, ja, dann sagst du, ach du, ich guck halt mal die Soap-Opera, ist für ein Projekt. Spannend ist zumindest an dem Film, dass da werden so paar Szenen zuhause gezeigt, wo so halt so zwei Jugendliche, die Hacker-Protagonisten sind, gezeigt werden. Und da fallen halt so Real-Referenzen, so World of Warcraft, komm lass uns ein bisschen War-Driving machen. Und so merkst du, okay, also so ganz auf ganz abstrakter Ebene sich so ein paar Stichworte reingeholt. Und das Ganze schafft es aber wirklich nicht, an diesen Wargames, diesen ersten Film irgendwie anzuknüpfen, ja.
Das ist auch wirklich sehr schwierig, so eine Ikone auszugraben und dann zu glauben, man könnte da jetzt noch was nachliefern.
Na ja, da kommen wir vielleicht zu. Also bei Tron, würde ich sagen, ist es schon ein bisschen besser gelungen. Bei Wargames war es einfach, also es ist so ein bisschen Fremdschemium vom Bildschirmsitz, ach nee, bitte nicht das auch noch.
Tron hat ja in dem Moment auch gleich seinen zweiten Teil bekommen. Hab ich noch nicht gesehen, deswegen hab ich das gar nicht so präsent.
Und auch 2008 kommt The Girl with the Dragon-Tattoo, diese Trilogie fängt da an. Ich weiß immer nicht in welcher Reihenfolge. Vergebung, Vergeltung, Verdammnis. Wahrscheinlich habe ich es jetzt genau drei. Du kennst sie glaube ich nicht. Das ist halt eine Verfilmung von einer schwedischen Romanverfilmung. Und da gibt es halt zwei Protagonisten, den Journalisten und die Hackerinnen, die zusammenfinden und zusammen ein kniffliges Rätsel lösen. Die schwedischen Filme sind, ich fand sie beeindruckend von der Ästhetik. Ich finde ja so, skandinavische Filme sowieso haben jetzt so eine eigene Stilistik, dieses Unterkühlte und sowas leicht Depressives, dass das da so rüberkommt, aber in einem guten Sinne, so dass man es auch gerne anguckt. Und die Hackerin in dem Film sieht halt wirklich extrem cyberpunkig aus. Es ist extrem eigenständig. Es bewegt sich auch so gendermäßig, so ein bisschen zwischen den Welten. Es hat sowohl eine Freundin als auch wandelt halt auch mit dem Journalisten an, ohne jetzt so viel zu verraten. Aber es ist so ein bisschen post alles irgendwie, was da so ein bisschen durchscheint. Es gibt in den Filmen, das muss man vielleicht wirklich vorher als Warnung, wirklich die härtesten Vergewaltigungsszene, die ich je im Film gesehen habe. Also alle, die diesen Film gesehen haben, sagen, wenn man drüber spricht, spätestens eine, die sagt, aber die Vergewaltigungsszene, die war wirklich unglaublich heftig. Und vor allen Dingen gibt es halt die Rache Szene. Also es gibt sozusagen die Hackerin, die wird halt vergewaltigt in dem Film. Das heißt, sie ist das Opfer und dann schlägt sie aber zurück, aber wirklich volle Kanne. Ja, sodass du mit offenem Mund wirklich vom Fernseher sitzt denkst, so, und ich hab mit manchen Leuten diesen Film einfach nicht geguckt, weil es ist einfach too much irgendwie. Aber natürlich wichtig als Handlungtragend Moment für den Hacker, also für die Hackerin. Einerseits, wir haben jetzt wenige Hackerinnen bisher gehabt, einerseits sozusagen wird sie zum Opfer gemacht und andererseits übt sie aber Rache. Und ihre gesamte Handlung, den Film über, ist von diesem Erlebnis auch geprägt. Also man merkt halt, dass sie in dieser Situation war und das halt auch ihre gesamten Handlungen irgendwie prägt. Weil sie ist sozusagen, sie ist halt irgendwie strange. Man denkt so, sie verhält sich irgendwie abgefahren. Und man versteht das aber im Zusammenhang mit dieser Szene. Als die Hack-Szenen sind in dem Film, versuchen die das so ein bisschen. Die tippt dann so ein, so find Laptop oder so, auf so einer Pseudo-Shell irgendwie. Die sind ja, die sind okay gelöst. So zumindest, dass ein Publikum, das da nicht so drinsteckt, ungefähr versteht, was sie macht. Das Interessante ist, dass auch in den Büchern sehr stark thematisiert wird, dass sie immer Apple-Produkte nutzt. Das wird so ein bisschen schick dargestellt. Die hat halt immer so Apple-Geräte. Also irgendwie hat das gleich so einen coolen Touch, diese silbrigen Geräte, die sie da mit sich rumschleppt. Das ist also auf jeden Fall eine sehr spannende Geschichte. Und vor allen Dingen ist es spannend, weil es wenige Jahre später in Hollywood noch mal verfilmt wurde mit Daniel Craig in der Hauptrolle, was für viel Verwunderung gesorgt hat. Genau, James Bond. Der dann die Rolle der Hackerin gespielt hat? Nein, der den Journalisten natürlich gespielt hat. Nein, nein.
Aber wer spielt die Hackerin?
Ja, die kannte ich vorher noch nicht. Genau, The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo, 2011.
Rooney Mara.
Genau, Rooney Mara kannte ich. Ich war auf der Filmpremiere und das war spannend, die in echt zu sehen. Das war schon ein extremer Unterschied zwischen dieser Filmfigur und ähnlich. Der Film ist von David Fincher, ich fand, der hat viel schlechte Kritik bekommen. Ich fand den gar nicht so schlecht. Ich hab mich auch nicht darüber aufgeregt, dass man was nochmal verfilmt, weil man kann natürlich nicht verlangen, dass man in einem bestimmten Land, in dem man bestimmte kulturelle Codes gewöhnt ist, sich jetzt unbedingt die schwedisch-schwedische Original anguckt. Weil einfach durch die stilistischen Mittel kann man vielleicht einfach nicht viel damit anfangen. Ist halt so. Die Story ist aber eine spannende Story. Also wird die halt nochmal verfilmt und wird jetzt auch nicht auf 90 Minuten runtergekürzt worden. Also der war irgendwie genau 158 Minuten. Das ist ja für einen amerikanischen Film auch schon ein Schwergewicht. Er ist natürlich deutlich seichter. Also zum Beispiel auch diese Vergewaltigungsszene ist halt seichter, aber ist trotzdem auch für einen amerikanischen Film schon so, dass du denkst, ja, das ist schon hart. Also für einen amerikanischen Film, der im Kino gelaufen ist. Also wurde schon so ein bisschen in die Grenze bewegt. Und das Lustige ist aber, ich glaube, der ist von Sony Pictures. Eigentlich hat sie ja Apple Computer ausschließlich in der Verfilmung. Hat sie Apple Computer und Varios. Und alles, was mit Bildbearbeitung zu tun hat, macht sie immer mit den Apples. Und wenn es aber ums Hacken geht, dann nimmt sie immer die Varios. Also einerseits Product Plays sind aber auch einfach lustig. Das beachtet man einfach und in den Film guckt, dann muss man ein bisschen schmunzeln, wenn man sieht, was sie gerade für ein Gerät nimmt und was man versucht, mit welchem Gerät zu verdrängen.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht sogar realistischer, wenn ich das vielleicht nicht so gemeint war.
Na, ich weiß, ja. Du siehst jetzt auf einem Hacker-Kongress, siehst du ja mittlerweile relativ viel Apple Computer, die aufgeklappt werden.
Du siehst eine Menge Apple Computer, aber wenn du wirklich die Die-Hards mal dir da ran pirscht, dann geht auf einmal die Thinkpad-Quote doch spürbar nach oben. Also da gibt es schon noch einen Unterschied.
Genau, also das...
Weil wenn unter Kontrolle, dann richtig unter Kontrolle und das hast du halt mit Apple nicht.
Ich wage ja zu bezweifeln, ob man es mit einem Vario hat, aber... Genau, also das ist The Girl with the Dragon-Tattoo und genau, es ist eben... Er ist einfach spannend, weil er halt eine weibliche Hackerin halt mit in der Hauptrolle ist und nicht wie in Assassin's, worüber wir vorhin gesprochen haben.
Steht denn da jetzt dieses Hackerin-Sein irgendwie im Vordergrund oder ist das mehr eine Geschichte über diese Vergewaltigung?
Nein, es ist keine Geschichte über eine Vergewaltigung. Es geht eigentlich darum, der Journalist kommt durch einen Skandal in eine unangenehme Situation, muss sich beruflich so ein bisschen umorientieren, kriegt einen ominösen Anruf, dass er auf so einen Herrschaftssitz kommen soll und kriegt dort einen Rechercheauftrag. Da ist was ominöses passiert in der Vergangenheit und er soll rausfinden, was. Und die Hackerin hat vorher im Auftrag den Journalisten beleuchtet, um sozusagen rauszufinden, ob der wirklich geeignet ist und stößt dann im Laufe des Films zu ihm. Und die sind dann ein Team und sie muss immer wieder auch ihre Fähigkeiten einbringen. Also sie ist die Hackerin in dem Film. Die Vergewaltigungs-Szene steht nicht erstmal im direkten Zusammenhang mit dieser Recherche-Geschichte, um die sich nachher der ganze Film dreht, ist aber wichtig für den Charakteraufbau. Also da geht es sozusagen darum, die ist sozusagen Weißenkind, steht unter Obhut. Und diese Obhut wird sozusagen missbraucht, die wird sozusagen ständig, wird sie missbraucht. Eigentlich hat sie Geld, an das sie aber nicht rankann und ihre Lage wird missbraucht. Und das macht natürlich etwas mit ihr. Also das lässt etwas mit ihr geschehen. Das heißt, es geht in dem Film nicht um diese Vergewaltigung, aber trotz dessen siehst du am Anfang diese Szene und kannst sie nicht mehr vergessen über diese ganzen drei Teile. Ja und das ist auch für die, das ist halt auch ein Film, wo das halt nicht, das wird nicht runtergespielt, sondern es ist einfach wirklich, du sitzt wirklich mit offenem Mund da und es ist deswegen schon beeindruckend so. Und auch, dass du halt merkst, wie prägend das für einen Charakter ist, so ein Erlebnis. Aber es geht nicht darum. Genau, das ist die The Girl, oder das, genau, The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo, die David Fincher Verfilmung. Ich hab mir die vor ein paar Tagen nochmal angefangen anzugucken, hat einen der geilsten Vorspänner, die ich wirklich je gesehen hab. Der hat so einen Musik-Clip da so am Anfang gemacht, das muss man bei voller Lautstärke...
Das Original jetzt ist schön.
Nee, das ist das 2011 von Fincher. Einfach schick, da kriechen auch so Kabel durch die Gegend und so, also geht es auch ein bisschen um Visualisierung von Computern. Das fand ich schon ziemlich, war schon ziemlich cool gemacht. Ja, und dann, Tron Legacy, auch 2011. Wir haben ja vorhin, also wir haben ja gerade schon über WarGames 2 gesprochen und über die Gefahr, so einen wuchtigen Film nochmal weiterzuführen, womit man sich natürlich sehr in die Nesseln setzen kann und natürlich kannst du nach Tron, der in den 80ern einfach so Zeichen gesetzt hat, was willst du da 2011 noch machen? Also visuell kannst du ja mittlerweile in Filmen kaum noch wirklich ein Zeichen setzen. Also es ist ja wirklich, die Explosionen sind beliebig groß und mittlerweile ist ja mit postproduktischen Computer-Animationen so ziemlich alles realisierbar. Trotzdem finde ich, dass Tron Legacy unterhaltsam war, aber einfach unterhaltsam. Also man darf an diesen Film mit keinerlei Erwartung rangehen, das ist wichtig. Man darf nicht sagen, ich gucke mir jetzt mal die Fortführung dieses großartigen 80er-Jahre-Meisterwerks ran, aber wenn du da so rangehst und sagst, dann mal gucken, was Disney da gemacht hat, also Disney im Hintergrund behalten. Und vor allem, was sie daraus in 3D gemacht haben, das ist ja so einer dieser 3D-Filme, in dem 3D auch insofern funktioniert, als dass es viel im Computer spielt, also es spielt ja auch in dieser Computerwelt, da macht es natürlich, da macht es auch optisch Sinn, es zu machen. Also das funktioniert auch dann vom Gucken her. Es gibt ja viele Filme, wo du so 3D siehst und du denkst so... Why, genau. Also es sieht einfach blöd aus und du denkst dir, why? Wenn es in so einer virtuellen Welt spielt...
Das ist natürlich die perfekte Voraussetzung auch.
Genau, du hast die perfekten Voraussetzungen. Das heißt, es funktioniert optisch und es funktioniert, finde ich, auch von der Story her, ja? Also ich finde halt 3D eine durchaus valide Darstellungstechnologie, vor allen Dingen, wenn es Sinn macht, wenn du darüber was transportieren willst, über dieses Medium. Genau und in Tron Legacy gibt es eine kurze Hacker-Szene. Da bricht der Protagonist in der Firma ein und befreit die Software und der böse Hacker der Firma beendet dann sozusagen diesen Software-Ausbruch und diese Szene ist insofern interessant, weil der EMAX benutzt. Ich habe das so gesehen und war so unvorherhaut und dachte so, Moment mal, wir haben es auf Pause gedrückt, wir haben zurückgespult. Krass, der hat ja da eine Shell und tippt irgendwie ein Kill-9 und so. Das sind so ein paar Sekunden. Moment mal, ist das EMAX, indem er das macht und es gibt dazu einen schönen Blogpost von dem Visual Artist, der das gemacht hat. Der hat eigentlich diese ganzen, der hat so halt Visualisierung in diesem Film gemacht. Da gibt es so abgefahrene Darstellungen von der Erde, so in 3D und der hat das sozusagen mit eingebracht. Der ist irgendwie EMAX Nutzer und der hat das dann eingebracht. Das Spannende ist, dass die halt so ein extrem, also ja wirklich Nerd-Tool benutzen, aber das schaffen, dass es verständlich ist, weil der tippt einen Kill. Es funktioniert halt, weil du verstehst als Zuschauer, auch wenn du keine Ahnung von Technik hast, der tötet gerade irgendwas. Und für die Hacker gibt es noch das Bonbon dazu, dass er halt Kill minus 9 ein tippt und du sagst, alles klar, der beendet wirklich was. Und das fand ich spannend, dass halt nur so 2, 3 Sekunden in so einem totalen Hochglanzfilm sind, der überhaupt keinerlei Realitätsbezug ist. Und aber man sieht so, was so ein bisschen Beratung irgendwie tun kann, dass du plötzlich auch so eine bestimmte kulturelle Gruppe ansprechen kannst, dass sie sagt, hey, es wär spannend. Und dazu gab es natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen Blogs und auf Twitter und so. Das ging natürlich so ein bisschen rum, weil das natürlich schon irgendwie besonders war. Ansonsten von der...
So was immer schon so besonders ist, wenn sich mal die Realität aufgegriffen wird. Ja, es gibt auch so eine Szene, ich weiß nicht, ob du das überhaupt auf den Zeiger hast. Ich kann die jetzt leider nicht mehr so ganz genau beschreiben, aber irgendwo in Jurassic Park, der ist glaube ich von 93.
Ja, den habe ich mit auf der Liste drauf.
Da gibt es auch irgendwie, da spielt auch dann auch irgendwann mal so die Kontrolle über das Computernetz da eine große Rolle. Ich glaube schon so gegen Ende und dann fällt glaube ich sogar das Wort Unix in dem Zusammenhang. Also ich glaube der Typ erklärt irgendwie, dass er hier Unix benutzt oder Unix-Einsatz hat oder so, um dann irgendwas zu tun, gefolgt dann auch von irgendwie, so weit ich das erinnere, halbwegs realistischen Nagell mir nicht fest, kann auch sein, dass das jetzt total Voodoo war, die ich jetzt bloß verwechsel. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da so eine Szene. Muss ich vorhin schon daran denken, als du meintest, man konnte sich das dann leisten, das so als Nebenplot irgendwie noch mit rein zu werfen. Bei Tron ist es dann ja quasi schon ein Home-Run, aber eben auch in Dinosaurier-Filmen funktioniert auf einmal der Hacker. Das ist von 1993.
Genau, also von Tron, wie gesagt, ich würde Tron jetzt nicht in die Liste guter Filme einreihen, im Sinne von Filmen, die sowas auf den Punkt bringen, einzigartig und so, weil es wurde schon erzählt, aber es ist irgendwie auch nicht, man kann es einfach gucken. 2010 passierte noch was, das war spannend, auf dem Chaos-Kongress wurde 2010 im erweiterten Chaos-Programm ein Dokumentarfilm gezeigt, der Hacker hieß. Der Regisseur hat den im Kino Babylon vorgeführt, Alexander Biedermann. Der hat fünf Hacker begleitet, einfach eine Weile. Und das war halt spannend, dass da sozusagen jemand sich gewagt hat, sozusagen ans Publikum heran, ihm sozusagen selbst zu zeigen, was er über sie gefilmt hat. Und ich fand diesen Dokumentarfilm gar nicht so schlecht, weil der nicht wie viele andere Dokumentarfilme versucht hat, irgendwie jetzt Hacker-Kultur zu erzählen, das Geheimnis, sondern der hat die einfach nur so ein paar Leute begleitet. Und das waren so ein bisschen einfach strange Typen, aber es war nicht abwertend. Das war das Wichtige. Also der Film hat die nicht abgewertet. Der hat nicht gesagt, guckt mal, und so mit dem Zeigefinger drauf. Also der Verny wurde zum Beispiel gezeigt. Verneri, Steffen Verneri. Genau, Steffen Verneri. Der macht so Dienst manchmal in so Luftschutzbunkern oder so. Und das ist natürlich einfach bildgewaltig, wenn du das siehst, denkst du so krass. Und dann so ein...
Also diesen Vogel da in Japan, den fand ich ein bisschen...
Genau, du hast ihn gesehen in dem Film auch, ja?
Ich hab ihn gesehen, ich bin nicht so begeistert.
Also begeistert, ja, nee begeistert war ich nicht, aber ich fand es ein gutes Diskussionsangebot. Also es war zumindest mal, worüber man reden konnte.
Der Wissenschaftler, der kriegt da natürlich so drauf. Aber ich fand jetzt nicht, dass da so viel transportiert wurde und man am Ende wirklich das Gefühl hat, man blickt jetzt auf die Hacker-Kultur. Es gab noch so einen Security-Experten, der hat halt viel aus der Security-Szene erzählt. Aber das hat jetzt mit Hacker-Kultur meiner Meinung nach nichts zu tun.
Der Film heißt aber auch nicht Hacker-Kultur.
Nee, aber der heißt Hacker. Und es ist schon, finde ich schon, da wirft man schon ganz schön was in die Schale. Und da kann man dann nicht einfach mit der Realität eines Security-Experten und seinem normalen Business-Life kommen, weil da war jetzt nicht sehr viel mehr drin. Da steckt meiner Meinung nach nicht drin. Ich meine, Steffen hat da natürlich eine interessante Vergangenheit. Ob seine Gegenwart da jetzt so viel noch mit zu tun hatte, lasse ich mal offen. Wie gesagt, auch die Story da in Japan, verstörtes Kind, also naja, gut. Mark zur Diskussion einladen, die muss man dann aber auch echt führen.
Also ich finde an dem, der passt jetzt auch nicht ganz in die Reihe, weil ich eigentlich Dokumentationen nicht mit aufnehme. Da der, also ich fand auch zum Beispiel spannend, diesen Japaner, also das ist ja ein Deutscher, wirklich ein junger Mensch, der nach Japan gegangen ist, der ist Virenautor und arbeitet dann da glaube ich für eine Antivirenfirma. Und wirklich ein völlig ausgeflippter Typ, der war auch bei der Filmvorführung dann mit dabei und Steffen Vernieri war auch mit dabei. Und Steffen Vernieri hat ähnlich wie du argumentiert, wo bitte ist denn hier der Film über die Hackerkultur? Und der Regisseur hat gesagt, ich hab keinen Film über die Hackerkultur gemacht. Es geht mir nicht um die Motivation, sondern ich hab fünf Typen gezeigt. Und in diesem Film dreht sich so ein, also auch dieser Typ aus der Security-Szene, Marco Rogge, genau, die werden, irgendwas zieht sich durch diese Typen durch. So eine gewisse, in diesem Film eine gewisse Einsamkeit, die die alle ausstrahlen. Das ist meiner Meinung nach die Aussage von diesem Film. Und das ist das, worüber man diskutieren kann. Das kann man dann auch falsifizieren, kann sagen, es ist falsch. Aber das fand ich das Gute an dem Film, dass er da ein Statement macht. Also dass er sozusagen über fünf völlig verschiedenen Typen, die sind total unterschiedlich, ein junger Virenautor, der nach Japan ist, Stefan Vernieri, der eigentlich diese Geschichte hinter sich hat und so weiter. Aber es wird versucht, über alle diese fünf Typen, ohne herablassen zu sein. Weil herablassen fand ich ihn nicht. Also nicht sozusagen im Sinne von guckt euch diese skurrilen Vögel an und lacht mal. Irgendwas, irgendein Muster zieht sich durch diese fünf Personen durch. Und das fand ich gut als Gesprächsangebot zumindest. So, aber ich verstehe. Und es war halt auf der Vorführung war irgendwie klar, er kommt nicht gut an in der Hacker-Szene der Filme.
Ich war nicht bei dieser Vorführung, aber das ist klar.
Aber das ist halt, das ist natürlich kein Qualitätskriterium, ne? Weil natürlich ein Dokumentarfilm über etwas muss nicht bei denjenigen gut ankommen, über die es berichtet. Ja, weil, also ein Film über Scientology muss ja auch nicht bei Scientology so sein. Dann können wir mal, das ist mal ein extremes Beispiel.
Das ist an wir. Na gut. Ja gut, Hacker-Dokumentationen wären jetzt vielleicht nochmal ein Thema für sich. Das Fass machen wir aber jetzt nicht auf, weil ich glaube, da sind wir nicht so richtig darauf vorbereitet. Davon abgesehen sind wir jetzt auch schon ganz gut in die Länge geschossen. Was machen wir denn jetzt da draus aus diesen vielen Beispielen? Was ist dir denn sozusagen, hast du mal da versucht, eine Quersumme zu ziehen? Oder bleibt das alles nur anekdotisch?
Also ich habe noch, ich habe keinen abschließenden Text drüber geschrieben oder so, was sich eigentlich anbietet, das Ganze mal irgendwie zu einem Resümee zu ziehen. Ich bemerke bei mir zumindest, dass ich in den letzten 2, 3 Jahren weniger Interesse daran habe, neue Filme aufzunehmen, weil über den HKM-Film in den letzten Jahren nicht mehr viel Neues gekommen ist. Also er ist sozusagen, das habe ich ja auch gesagt, dass er so, irgendwann wird ihm auch der Actionheld wieder entgegengesetzt. Es kam noch The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo, das war jetzt noch eine wichtige Figur, aber er scheint im Moment, das kann sich ändern, im Moment ein wenig auserzählt zu sein.
Hacker sind out.
Hacker sind Mainstream. In Fernsehserien, es gibt Fernsehserien wie Eljes und so, da ist es jetzt einfach Bestandteil. Es gibt halt immer einen Hacker, das ist nichts Besonderes mehr. Man schaltet auch nicht mehr Fernsehserien ein, weil da ein Hacker drin ist. Wenn man sagt, so ein Hacker ist, muss ich mir unbedingt angucken. Während man vielleicht in den 70er, 80er schon McGyver und auch für Feusti für ein Trio, da waren halt so ein bisschen, das war schon spannend, da den Hacker zu sehen. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so. Das ist auserzählt. Ich glaube, was jetzt schon rausgekommen ist, es gibt halt bestimmte Zeitabschnitte, in denen man bestimmte Muster einfach aufmachen kann. Ich weiß nicht, wo Datenhandschuhe mit der der 90er auftauchen und auch wieder verschwinden. Wozu ich noch keinen abschließenden Urteil habe, ist eben diese Sex- und Hackergeschichte, die eben bis heute halt in so einer extrem sexuellen Aufladung resultiert. Da ist dann die Frage, tun das nicht alle Action? Tun das nicht alle Helden in Hollywood? Sind die nicht alle sexy an irgendeinem Punkt? Das wäre so die eine These, die andere... Ja, ein Komma vertreten. Genau, das wäre die eine These, die andere These, können wir sich aber nochmal kritisch auseinandersetzen. Und natürlich ist die letztendliche Frage, die für mich dann spannend ist, wo ist wirklich diese Wechselbeziehung? Wo taucht die immer wieder auf? Was ist mit dem Modem-Verkäufen, nachdem Wargames rausgekommen ist? Da kann es halt so schön statistisch abwesend...
Was ist mit dem nach Matrix?
Genau, was ist nach Matrix? Also was sozusagen... Also das da, was war das? Man ahnt das irgendwie, aber was war das wirklich? Das kann man halt nochmal versuchen, so ein bisschen griffiger zu machen.
Und wurden mehr rote oder mehr blaue Beine verkauft? Ich befürchte blaue.
Und dann hatte ich... Das war ein persönliches Resümee. Sozusagen hatte ich schon öfters jetzt Anfragen von Regisseuren, die irgendwie mitbekommen haben, dass ich mich mit dem Thema beschäftige, die halt gefragt haben, ob ich nicht irgendwie mal beraten kann, weil sie gerade ein Drehbuch haben. Also man hat ja ein Drehbuch und dann wird's verfilmt. Und du kannst natürlich, wenn du am Anfang übers Drehbuch guckst, schon viel rausreißen. Also zumindest, wenn du halt einen Film machst mit Realbezug, kannst du halt grobe Schnitzer einfach rausmachen. Also so dieses Jahr Zoom doch hundertmal ins Bild rein. Ja, komm, mach das mal noch scharf. Und welche Serie ist das? In Navy Series gibt es so eine amerikanische Serie. Da gibt es auch ganz oft Hackszenen, da sind die dann zu zweit an einer Tastatur. Das ist großartig. Also zwei Personen tippen jeweils mit zwei Händen auf einer Tastatur. Und sagen, ja hier, ich exploit jetzt die Firewall. Das ist eigentlich so eine Krimiserie, aber es gibt immer mal wieder den Hack schnell. Das ist immer so eine geheime FBI-Hack. Ja komm, hack das doch mal schnell. Und dann geht das auch mal so dreißig zu zweit. Wie heißt das?
Navy?
Navy CIS.
Genau.
Und, genau, das ist natürlich die Frage, inwiefern es ist wichtig, dass man in Filmen bestimmte Dinge gerade zieht. Inwiefern ist diese Erwartung? Für mich ist ein Resümee eben mit diesem Erzählen über Hackerfilme zu sagen, guckt euch die Filme nicht nur an, ob sie realistisch sind und euch gefallen, sondern denkt auch wirklich drüber nach, wie sie auf Leute wirken, die nicht in dieser Szene drinstecken. Und verteufelt die Filme deswegen nicht nur, sondern die stoßen irgendwie einen Diskurs an und die machen auch was mit euch. Also egal, wie kritisch ich an diese Filme rangehe, irgendwie prägen sie mich oder haben mich schon geprägt, weil man sie als 14-Jährige jetzt vielleicht nicht so filmkritisch ist, wie man das mit 25 ist, wo man dann schon nochmal mehr drüber reflektiert, sagt, okay, es ist ein kulturelles Werk, ein Kunstwerk und so. Es gibt eben nicht diese Trennung zwischen dem Hacker im Film und dem Hacker auf dem Kongress. Das sind nicht zwei völlig voneinander losgelöste Personen, sondern sie stehen in einem Diskurs zueinander und beeinflussen sich gegenseitig. Das ist ein schmerzhafter Prozess, sich ein bisschen dessen bewusst zu werden, auch zu sagen, okay, ich bin auch von Hollywood beeinflusst und auch vom schwedischen The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo und so weiter. Aber diese Beeinflussung findet einfach statt. Und wenn man das erst mal anerkannt hat, macht es auch wieder Spaß, sich dann damit zu beschäftigen. Und dann kann man da auch anders mit umgehen, also wenn man sich dessen bewusst wird und es auch akzeptiert.
Ja, das fällt mir schon fast nichts mehr dazu ein hier. Das war auf jeden Fall ein wilder Ritt. Man muss natürlich jetzt nochmal Back to the Drawing Board und die erste Version von dem Computerhacker, die die Ampelnetze lahmlegt, anschauen. Ich denke, ich werde auch in den ein oder anderen Filmen noch mal reingucken. Manches kannte ich, manches kannte ich nicht, manches habe ich bisher einfach noch nicht wahrgenommen. Aber es steckt auf jeden Fall eine Menge drin. Ich bin mal gespannt vor allem, wie sich das so in der nächsten Zukunft entwickeln wird. Weil man hat irgendwie das Gefühl, die totale Überhöhung ist mit Matrix so ein Peak-Hacker. Was soll schon nach Jesus noch kommen?
Jetzt wo du sagst, fällt mir natürlich ein, was fehlt im Moment noch, sind die Anonymos-Filme. Also die das Ganze Hollywood-mäßig aufbereiten. Weil du hast ja diese lauten Hacker-Bewegungen in den letzten Jahren, diese kollektive, diese schwer greifbaren Objekte, die interessanterweise mit V for Vendetta, also auch auf einen Film- bzw. Comic-Referenzieren, zumindest in ihrer Optik. Das ist ein schwieriges Thema. Aber da wird sicherlich noch einiges kommen, weil das muss natürlich nochmal alles aufgearbeitet werden. Und das ist spannend, wie das dann dargestellt wird und ob das dann die Helden sind oder die Anti-Helden. Und das könnte dann der Punkt sein, in dem es wieder interessant wird, sich dann mit dieser filmischen Auseinandersetzung zu beschäftigen. Kannst du denn mehr sagen zu It's Coming? Das klang eben so wissend.
Ich weiß, dass da gerade was... Ich kann es ja aber nicht so genau sagen, dass ich jetzt hier auf irgendein Release-Datum zeigen könnte, aber da gibt es gerade wieder so eine Produktion, die sich gerade so rumspricht und wo noch nicht genau abzusehen ist, was da alles thematisiert wird. Aber es hat unter Garantie mit Wikileaks und Anonymous zu tun. Das bewegt natürlich da gerade die Gemüter. Und es war klar, dass sich das Hollywood nicht lange entgehen lassen wird. Das ist vor allem sozusagen auch so ein bisschen insofern interessant, als das eben bisher... Das zeigt jetzt hier auch so diese Liste, gerade diese Überhöhung mit Matrix. Also es hat so lange gedauert, bis überhaupt erst mal diese ganze Subkultur wahrgenommen wurde. Beziehungsweise überhaupt ist es ja auch eine Umarmung des digitalen, virtuellen, meiner Auffassung nach ja umfangreichsten Änderungen, gesellschaftlichen Änderungen, die dieser Planet wahrscheinlich ausgesetzt gewesen sein wird. Also Strom, Telefon etc. klar, das war alles wichtig, industrielle Gesellschaft. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht erwarte ich, dass diese digitale Gesellschaft, diese Wissensgesellschaft, wie man auch immer sie nennen möchte, dass die Veränderung, die langfristig durch das Internet und all dem, was da noch folgen mag, kommen wird, das wird einfach nochmal diesen Planeten auf eine Art und Weise transformieren, wie man das jetzt so mit dem Umwälzungen der Zeit davor nicht vergleichen kann, zumal sie in gewisser Hinsicht trotz aller globalen Auswirkungen doch auch immer noch sehr regional beschränkt waren. Das waren Dinge, die vor allem in Europa passiert sind, natürlich auch in den USA. Und jetzt geht's irgendwie wirklich überall ab. Und der Hacker-Typus war vielleicht auch wichtig, um sozusagen Protagonisten zu haben für all diese Ideen. Schon zu Beginn in der Literatur, mehr oder weniger als Science-Fiction-Vorlage, dann hat sich das eben auch real manifestiert. Und ist so ein bisschen auch so ein Typus, an dem man jetzt so viel immer festmachen kann, den man sozusagen nutzt, um eine Geschichte zu begleiten. Egal, ob es jetzt der Bösewicht oder der Superheld ist, funktioniert ja offensichtlich auf beiden Ebenen. Ja, und jetzt kommt sozusagen so die digitale Allgegenwart mit ihren Auswüchsen wie Anonymous und anderen Dingen.
Ich hoffe ja, dass John McAfee verfilmt wird. Ja, also das sind ja dann so, also auch bei Anonymous, das ist ja das Spannende, das sind ja Geschichten.
Du spielst jetzt an seine Flucht da aus.
Ja, genau, ich weiß nicht, ob du die Auflösung gelesen hast, was er da getrieben hat. Der hat ja einen Post gemacht, warum er geflohen ist und was er da gemacht hat. Ich kann es gar nicht in Worten wieder fassen. Der hat Dutzende von Labtos, also der hatte doch diese krasse Hausdurchsuchung bei sich, und da hatte er danach die Schnauze voll. Daraufhin hat er mehrere Dutzend Labtos gekauft, alle mit Spy-Software versehen und hat angefangen, die so an Funktionsträger und deren Lebensgefährten und so zu verteilen und prostituierte auf die angesetzt und hat so ein riesen Leak-Ding daraus gemacht, dass du wirklich, wenn du diesen Blogpost liest, denkst du, das kannst du dir in Hollywood nicht ausdenken, diese Nummer, weil man hat ja vorher gedacht, warum flüchtet, was ist denn mit dem los? Was macht der denn da? Und wenn du das gelesen hast, denkst du, okay, da wäre ich auch abgehauen. Der hatte sich da komplett mit dem ganzen Staat angelegt und hatte allen Grund, um sein Leben zu fürchten. Und das ist natürlich spannend, dass du diese Geschichten jetzt auch einfach auf einer realen Grundlage alle verfilmen kannst.
Früher musste man noch Science-Fiction-Autoren bedienen.
Na, Wikileaks liefert ja Stoff ohne Ende bis heute, ist aber noch nicht zu Ende. John McAfee ist einfach wirklich ganz großer Content.
Warte ich noch gar nicht auf einen Zeiger.
Viel Sprechen, einfach abends werden wir ein bisschen rein.
Ja Caspar, ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es auch, oder?
Ja.
Das war ein umfangreicher Flug hier durch die Filmen- und Medienlandschaft. Dann machen wir jetzt hier den Topf mal zu. Zeit ist es auf jeden Fall. Ich sage vielen Dank.
Danke auch.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war es bei CRE und bald geht es weiter.